is Wednesday right
um being nine o'clock I will open the
public hearing for Senate bill 130.
and we will be in recess for just a few
minutes
good morning we're reopening the
public hearing on Senate Bill 130 and we
recognize
Grant Bosey
speaking for
Senator Abbas
thank you very much good morning
chairman Roy members of the criminal
justice committee I'm Grant bosse from
the New Hampshire Senate introducing
Senate Bill 130 on behalf of Senator
Darrell Abbas the Bill's Prime sponsor
this bill came from a request from the
judicial branch which is responsible for
ensuring the safety of all of New
Hampshire's courts the police standards
and training Council has the expertise
and infrastructure to provide high
quality training for law enforcement and
security officers but it currently lacks
authority under RSA 106-l to provide
that training to court security officers
sb-130 would enable the police standards
and training Council to enter into an
agreement at the request of Chief
Justice McDonald to Institute a court
security officer education training and
certification program this would allow
New Hampshire to standardize security
training across all our courts while
preparing officers for the specific
challenges of keeping our courthouses
safe and secure if you have questions
for Senator Abbas I'll make sure to get
you an answer but for today today I
would defer to direct a Skipper and the
judicial branch on the need for this
legislation Senator Abbas thanks you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 130. thank you
thank you very much and please tell
Senator Abbas um we're sorry that he
couldn't break away and join us today
thank you
at this point I
the chair calls
um
turning head
that's fine
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch with me at the table
is Diane Martin the director of the
administrative office of Courts also in
the room just in case there are any
question Jason Jordan hazy is our
manager of security operations so there
may be if you have any questions that he
may need to address he's available and
director sipa of police standards and
training is also in the room if there
are any questions that he may need to
address
um as Mr bossy said this is a request of
the ability that is the request of the
judicial branch currently we have court
security officers who manage all the
security operations within our circuit
courts
they train themselves so they develop
their own training program they
Implement that training and they train
themselves and as I've talked about many
times before this committee one of our
significant issues is resources
so we're taking resources away from our
security Personnel whose job it is to
provide security within our courthouses
and developing on an annual basis
training for our court security officers
and our sheriffs who are doing this
court security within this in the
Superior Courts
and really that is a drain on really
what it is is their primary focus the
other aspect of of why we brought this
bill forward is that
um
we're in we're we're not professional
trainers within our court security
program we have individuals who are
experts at providing court security but
they are not sort of in their day-to-day
business staying up to date on the
latest training issues the latest sort
of uh
ways in which court security needs to be
managed from a from a security basis so
what we would like to do and what this
bill does is simply is it simply
provides an enabling statute to
authorize police standards and training
to enter into an agreement with the
judicial branch to be able to provide
that level of training that we believe
is appropriate for court security
officers into with the Chief Justice
with Mr Jordan hazy the sheriffs and
police standards and training developed
that program sort of building off of our
existing training program so what this
bill does is simply creates it simply
enables police standards and training to
enter into that conversation with the
judicial branch to implement a court
security training program through police
standards and training
um the other aspect of of why this bill
is being brought forward is just the
inherent uh nature of having our own
people train ourselves you know best
practice does provide for having a third
party come in and oversee that training
and that would be police standards and
training uh in this case so we want to
be able to you know have our folks
trained by folks who are professional
trainers who are maintaining sort of the
day-to-day knowledge of the latest
issues in in training
um but all that said our court security
officers remain employees of the
judicial branch so they are still
subject to all the policies and
procedures that all judicial branch
employees are required to uh to follow
it at all times
um
and I'll just turn it over to director
Martin just to sort of talk through some
of the conversations she's had with
police standards and training and how
sort of we look forward to working with
them in terms of developing this program
good morning members of the committee
um as Richard said I am the director of
the administrative office of the courts
and the court security function Falls
within the administrative office and I
am very proud to be able to work with
all of these individuals who do this job
we have a variety of people who do it
some are retired law enforcement some
are not and so training is very very
important to the work that they do
because of the various types of
individuals that we get and so when the
Chief came into this role a couple of
years ago he identified this as a
priority for him to Institute Training
work with police standards in training
and to really professionalize our court
security there from an equipment
training all of the resources that they
need to do this job well and so we
reached out to police standards and
training and have been engaging with
director skippa to try to work on this
concept so we would love to have your
support to move this forward and to
engage with them to make this happen
thank you very much with that we
conclude our comments but we'll be happy
to answer any questions
thank you um I just have a couple of
quick questions so
would this would the current officers be
be mandated to go to this training as
well or would they be grandfathered is
there a physical fitness aspect to it
that you're contemplating so thank you
for the question the the exact details
are have still need to be worked out
there clearly are going to be different
levels of experience of folks coming
into our program and people are
currently in the program whether they
have a long history in law enforcement
or not will sort of depend on possibly
the the modules that they would have to
engage in
um and and so there I think there's
going to be a one a phase in of existing
employees and then within as new
employees come in in our undergoing the
training you know they may already have
undertaken some of the training that
would be in all of the modules and only
to some of them details of that program
still need to be worked out in the in
the conversations between the judicial
branch and police standards and training
thank you
any further questions from the committee
representative Muse
yes thank you
um one of the things I'm trying to
trying to figure out is how the training
uh that would be offered under police
standards and training might differ from
uh the training that's offered now in
terms of subject matter in terms of
length in terms of certification
requirements can you maybe go one more
level of detail sure um so thank you for
the question I think the again while the
details still need to be worked out as
as I mentioned we do currently have a
program that we've developed internally
so I think that is going to be the the
bones of of any training program that is
conducted by police standards and
training and if you want more detail in
terms of the existing CSO program either
director Martin or Jason can speak more
detail than I can but I think what in
terms of process Jason Jordan hazy our
Securities manager is going to be
working with the sheriffs and police
standards and training and sort of
taking our current program and
implementing that through police
standards and training but adding on to
that any additional sort of things that
they say you know this is this you may
need to bring this into your program
stuff we haven't thought of but maybe
saying you know here's an area that you
may need to implement through your
people that you're not currently
training on we may say okay that's you
know another module we want to add into
the program but I think the bones of it
will be our existing program
see no further questions actually um I
have one real quick is are you aware of
is there is there a national
um set of best practices or standards
certifications that that are already in
existence uh I'm not sure if there's a
standard Jason can answer that but we do
participate with the national Center and
Jason and his team participate with that
group in determining what appropriate
standards are is there actually a
standard
however I have actually begged the
national Center for state courts for
years to come up with that criteria and
actually uh volunteered my time to help
uh come up with that sort of criteria to
help us you know as we kind of maintain
our training programs so we could act
theoretically be on The Cutting Edge of
setting up a standard yes sir okay which
which again you know folding police
standards into our sort of training
program again like you said it makes a
good program better okay um and I hate
to do this but since you talked you have
to fill out a pin card no problem at all
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you thank
you very much
um based on everything you heard direct
description do you feel you need to add
anything or
just don't want to fill out that card do
you
okay thank you
um so you know further questions is
there anyone else wishing to testify who
is not testified on this bill
see none I closed the public hearing
yeah
in the committee will be in recessed
until 9 30.
foreign
at this point we are opening the public
hearing on Senate Bill 249
and I
who's going to always wow Senator Abbas
is here
the chair recognizes Senator Abbas
Ed
good morning Mr chairman members of the
House criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee it's an honor to be back here
if for those who didn't served on this
committee last term I used to chair this
committee
and representative Rory was my vice
chair so it's a pleasure to be back
hopefully this goes well
so Senate Bill 249 this for the members
that were on this committee last term
this language May looks very familiar
uh this language which I helped draft
actually pass in the Senate twice
it was part of a much larger bill I
believe it was Senate Bill 294 or maybe
292.
and what this this is a limited
policy it applies to issues of bail but
we're only addressing situations where a
person has been arrested for a crime
and we're talking about a felony a Class
A misdemeanor or drunk driving
all other class B uh misdemeanors and
violations would not apply
if that person's released on bail
pending their trial and gets arrested
again
and now we're talking about another
felony Class A misdemeanor or drunk
driving
and they get released a second time now
when upon being released the third time
if they were getting to get arrested
again while the first and second charge
is still open
that and that would also have to be a
felony a Class A misdemeanor or drunk
driving
at that point there's going to be a
presumption
the burden is now going to shift to the
defendant because the presumption is if
they were released they will not abide
by the conditions of their release by
not getting arrested for any type of
bail conditions I've ever heard of or
seen one of the conditions is is that
you not commit any new offenses you
don't get arrested again
so what this is saying is
because you violate those conditions
twice already on offenses that you can
go to jail for or drunk driving
we're not going to give you the benefit
of the doubt now that you're just gonna
abide by these conditions and we're we
hear the term Catch and Release Catch
and Release I don't really like that
term but that's where it comes from is
where someone gets arrested they get
released they get arrested again
the people are getting arrested for
multiple offenses and these are all in a
short period of time
so think about the amount of resources
between the court the police
we're doing a lot of putting a lot of
time into and money and expenses into
dealing with this and
there's no consequence for violating the
conditions of your release I would
suggest if you don't support this policy
you examine why you even have conditions
of your release in the first place
why have them if you can violate them
without consequence
in my my humble opinion that is in
unnecessary provision at that point I'm
not agreeing that we go in that
direction because that would basically
turn the entire bail system upside down
but if you continue to violate your
conditions there needs to be a
consequence
and this is setting a clear policy of
when it would apply the existing law
does permit it says the burden will
shift and there'll be a rebuttable
presumption but is is different
interpretations of when that rebuttable
presumption would apply is the second
arrest this makes it very clear I'm
going to do it on the third time and
that's it and that's how it should be
it's a very clear policy on when it
would be applicable it also I believe
it's very reasonable I mean think about
this you have to be arrested for
jailable offenses
three times on three separate occasions
for different crimes different events in
a short period of time
that's what this applies to this is a
reasonable policy IT addresses up what I
would say an unintended consequence of
what bail reform was passed a few years
back and I think this is a good policy
for public safety concerns and I'll
answer any questions
representative Peru
why are we waiting until the third time
and not the second did you get pushed
back if you tried the second
well that's a good question
so
considering that this policy didn't pass
last term at as being the third time I
don't believe it didn't pass because
people thought it was
to Win It
so I wouldn't although I wouldn't
necessarily be opposed to such a policy
I do believe in working together and
trying to come to a compromise on a on a
practical reasonable policy and
sometimes these crimes aren't always
related so drunk driving yes it's a
public safety concern but it is a Class
B misdemeanor so if you had a you know a
violent offense then three months later
you get a drunk driving charge those are
separate from each other that you don't
have the same victim per se so I
understand there are circumstances where
this can be a very tight policy I think
three is more than reasonable and it's
really no excuse for that especially
after being arrested the second time
representative salig thank you for
taking my question
um
yesterday some of us were to go toward
the court system and talk with them
about some of the issues and one thing
that was apparent was the extreme
shortage of public defenders which was
leading some people to have their trials
continued for six to nine months at
least before arraignment
um how are those people if they have no
attorney for six months eight months ten
months a year
how long is are they subject to to this
if they have perhaps an addiction issue
or some other challenge
so I this won't solve the shortage of
public defenders
either way whether regardless of whether
the case is continued if that's done by
agreement that's the choice of the
defendant to leave the case open uh I
would say I would not advi if I would
not advise for in continuance because
you have a right to a speedy trial there
are some benefits of
moving the case forward but there's also
benefits perhaps strategy wise of
delaying the case I won't get into the
many fact patterns of why but that's a
if that's ultimately the right to have a
speedy trial if they want to raise that
argument they can but
in this case it's still three times
that's another reason for why perhaps
maybe two you know having this strict
policy on a second offense might be too
stringent
because it can be delayed at no fault of
the uh defendant but it's not an it's
not an automatic situation where the
person will be held awaiting trial they
have to then rebut the presumption
explain why they if they are released
they're not going to now get arrested a
fourth time if they can present that
argument in the persuasive Manner and
explain why these are our separate
offenses perhaps if they were
um had substance abuse issues and
weren't getting treated but then gut
treatment it's perhaps less likely
they'll violate the conditions of their
release so I think that's an argument
that you have to evaluate on a
case-by-case basis
and just to maybe answer your question
if you recall um what we heard was if
they were being held the public defender
was assigned right away versus if
they're out that's when the six months
we year thing so
if that helps
um
oh representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I agree with the spirit and and that
my question is how does this reconcile
with innocent until proven guilty
because at this point you're what you're
saying is and I'm sure that there's you
know it's demonstrable something that is
violent or you know that kind of stuff
my question is how do you reconcile it
you know them not actually being
convicted of a crime and still suffering
the consequences of
you know being deemed as guilty of that
crime so innocent until proven guilty
that Beyond a reasonable doubt that
that's the that's the trial standard so
you're there's a presumption of innocent
yes
what we're talking about is when you're
released
on bail there's conditions of your
release for example do not use drugs or
alcohol that can be conditioned if you
violate the condition of your release
the the state and this is a common
throughout all the states that they
actually are allowed to revoke your bail
whether it's pending trial or for a
certain time period
uh one of those conditions and I've sat
through more arraignment hearings than I
can count I've represented
many criminal defendants I can't I can't
uh give you an exact number I've never
encountered a circumstance where one of
the conditions of their release was to
not get arrested
for any new offenses
so what's happening is the violation of
the conditions of their release is the
fact that they got arrested and charged
the new fence and that's why the
language uses a probable cause it says
probably it says probable cause because
that's the standard for the arrest if if
you go to court and you defeat it on a
probable cause argument it won't
actually result in your bill being
revoked because you've now defeated that
case
representative Sue Newman
yes thank you for taking my question you
had mentioned in your testimony a
rearrest within a short period of time
is there a definition of what this short
period of time is or does that depend on
what their current bails status is does
that drive it
the the time period is not in here when
I say short period of time look at this
way
the majority overwhelming majority of
the population is able to live their
lives without getting arrested never
mind three times while the first and
second case is still open so I say short
period of time relatively you talk about
within one year time period
give or take to be arrested that many
times you're dealing with a person who's
not abiding by the conditions of their
beliefs but also committing multiple
criminal offenses
without without consequence to the
conditions of the release in the first
place and when you have a bail hearing
the state is is at their discretion they
can argue for a high cash Bill if they
want they can argue a lot of different
conditions but part of it the conditions
of the releases it's often even done by
agreement of the parties
we agree on these conditions and they
don't follow the conditions so
I I think that's something that needs to
be factored in now we're talking about a
third violation so short period of time
I would say is
you know while the first one's still
open so
representative Muse
thank you for for taking my question
um looking at the bill
um one of the things that I see is I see
the addition of your language
but right up above it there's a lot of
stuff that's uh that struck out and some
of the things that are struck out that
first line
something I'm I'm curious about is it
appears that we already have a
rebuttable presumption in the statute
that somebody if if somebody who is
already on release doesn't abide with
the conditions of their release that's
something the court can look at and bail
my understanding is that it's within the
power of the court to actually revoke
Baal
so one of the things I struggle with a
little bit in these bills is when I look
at our current statute I see that the
power to do that is there the
flexibility to do that is there but for
some reason uh it doesn't appear to be
getting done
and what I'm curious about is whether or
not you think this actually fixes that
problem
thank you for the question what I can
tell you is this this is the current law
is being interpreted and applied
differently
depending on where you get arrested and
which court you're appearing and which
judge you're appearing from
and you would like to think that it's
the zip code of where you can get
arrested shouldn't they play into it or
the judge that happens to be sitting in
that court on that particular day
so that to me this is a clearer policy
it's also not clear when so the if the
burden shifts and now there's a
rebuttable assumption to the defendant
it's not clear what happens to that
party
it the law is actually not written clear
on how the court should handle that
it doesn't say what the what the
consequence is of violating the
conditions it kind of leaves it
open-ended so you're getting
inconsistent results this creates a
clear policy on what and I I would even
suggest this was the intent of the
original draft
but it also makes it clear what happened
on the third offense whether the
original draft if you were to interpret
it you know really narrowly and strictly
they could be held on the second offense
this makes it clear when that
presumption shifts and what would happen
when it does and how to overcome it
follow up please follow up
as a defense attorney and I believe you
said that you uh you have defended uh
numerous clients
um in criminal cases
one of the things
um
one of the things that um
one of the things that I think is part
of our judicial system is the idea that
uh that the circumstances of different
individuals are different which is one
of the reasons why we have uh judicial
and prosecutorial discretion
um it looks like this particular bill
would remove that uh that discretion in
these cases do I have that right
I can my experience is that if the
prosecutor does not want the person to
be held and they make that
recommendation that is something that
the court would favorably take into
consideration
when applying this policy
what I will tell you the prosecutor if
they if they don't want to actually
prosecute the person and the person's
been arrested I'm surprised that they
would be advancing the case in the first
place
I would think there's an ethical issue
when you file a case whether criminal or
civil there's a obligation that you
intend on seeing that case through
and if they don't intend on seeing it
through they shouldn't be issuing the
complaint or addressing any further it's
not just the fact that they've been
arrested they've been arrested with a
new charge and that charge you would
have to have probable cause
so that's that's my take I don't think
you're taking the discretion away
thank you representative Bolden
thanks for taking my question
um the fiscal note is interesting it's
really long but it has a lot of zeros
it says on the back the judicial branch
assumes this bill would result in an
increase in the number of Bill hearings
and Associated costs but they're unable
to quantify the size of the increase and
then they also talk in the next I think
the next last paragraph about the impact
on County budgets
um which is you know something that we
uh the house member set
um as far as the cost of running the
county jails but they're very clear that
they have no idea what the increase
um
tax rate would be because it depends on
so many factors do you have any
estimates for that
if anyone gave an estimate it would be
they would be guessing because there's
no way to really quantify how many
people are going to get get arrested who
are already out on bail for their second
and third offense so will there be a
fiscal impact on the court if you're
going to have people in court people
being held is a fiscal impact there's
also a fiscal impact of processing all
these extra cases is a fiscal impact on
the county sheriff's department and on
law enforcement of constantly having to
arrest the same person one of the
reasons why I support drunk driving
being in here and this was a few years
back I had someone call me and it wasn't
a constituent but someone in New
Hampshire and they had a family member
who was arrested for drunk driving five
times in a two-month period and they
were wondering how could that happen and
I had to explain well they haven't been
convicted of the first so we've been not
being charged the second third or fourth
offense
what's happening is your system your
bail system is a problem
this person kept getting released and
for someone to
not having extensive criminal record and
all of a sudden have five drunk driving
arrests in a short period of time that
seemed like a person in crisis and
simply releasing that person I didn't
think was a benefit to the public or to
that person at this point I don't know
though the details of each of those
charges and what went into each one of
them but they have that many in one
period of time you're talking about how
many resources are going in you have to
arrest the person you have to then
process the person then is it the case
goes to court it's now an open file if
they have a public defender or they're
hiring private counsel it's clogging up
the court system so this is the Hope is
this this will cut down on the amount of
repeat offenses which also has a fiscal
impact they're thinking in a positive
way so hopefully they offset in an
equitable way but there's no way to
determine that
okay so you um thanks for taking my
follow-up questions so you do anticipate
an increased cost to the state judicial
system and the county budgets because
um this the
the courts have made it very clear to
this committee that they're underfunded
currently and that they need more
funding and more staff when we were
touring yesterday they were showing us
how there was someone working a job she
doesn't normally work because they were
short staffed so are you so you are
saying you're aware that this would
increase costs to an already underfunded
department and you're okay with that but
I'm hoping that I I think it will have
an increased fiscal impact I'm hoping
that the house passes a budget and I'm
really hopeful that when I when the
budget makes it to the Senate that is
adequate funding for the courts because
Beyond this policy nothing's and I've
seen this nothing's more frustrating
than watching someone get paid 300 an
hour to sit on the bench waiting for a
case to be called I you know as I I
don't feel that that's a good attorneys
are expensive and if you're paying them
to sit there because it's overcrowd I
don't
that's that's
um
that's not good money well spent so if
you keep it moving along in an efficient
manner you have police that are waiting
for their case to be called there's
Court interpreters there's a lot of
negative fiscal consequences of having
an understaffed Court
so I would I would support uh adequate
Staffing the court
not sacrificing Public Safety
well representative representative
excuse me representative Murray first
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question and I actually
just had two quick ones um one I was
wondering
um if there was a reason for striking
out the language relating to financial
conditions for bail and pre-trial
detentions and then my second question
was if um this bill coincides well with
Senator Susie's bill Senate Bill 252
where if they clash with each other
thanks for the question and the second
part of it with Senate Bill 252 which I
also support and it's I believe that's
an excellent policy they do not conflict
their separate sections of the bail
statute and the section about the cash
bill being struck out there is another
section
in the bill chapter that specifically
addresses the uh cash bail and if a
person's being held simply because they
can't pay their bill
they don't have the financial resources
to do so then there needs to be a
written finding that part is struck out
because I don't personally in my opinion
I don't think it's a good policy well
the person's been arrested a second time
but will increase their bail from 500 to
a thousand dollars I don't think that's
really a great policy in in a sense that
you're just increasing the bail that has
to do with whether they're gonna uh show
up at the next court hearing that's
really what that's factoring in
so that seems to be more of a punitive
penalty by increasing the bail
this is strictly we're not we're not
going to necessarily offer you bail
because you keep or to be harder to get
bail because you keep violating the
conditions whether you're on personal
recognizes or paid a cash bill I don't
think is relevant to this policy
uh Senator this seems like it's actually
a relaxed
excuse me relaxation of the present
situation do I understand that if
somebody is on released on bail and
violates the conditions of Baal
the police have the discretion to take
them to the county jail immediately
without a bail commissioner
so this is in fact
relaxing that situ that taking that
discretion away is it not
I think what this is doing is creating a
clear policy of when a person violates
the conditions of their release by
getting arrested while released on bail
already multiple times when it's going
to be invoked and it's I think there's
an important
important subject that doesn't always
get talked about is consistency in how
the law is applied this is a very clear
policy of when it's going to apply you
hear some people who get arrested a
second time and they're held and someone
else doesn't and they they make all
sorts of theories why and rather than
have that debate this is a clear policy
it's it's not it's not subject to debate
it's very straightforward of when it
would apply so perhaps that when people
say taking the discretion away that's
discretion does lead to some people to
speculate on why this you know
statistics suggesting these laws are
having a disproportionate impact on
certain communities well when there's a
clear unambiguous law of when a person
is going to likely be held
I think that's a better policy for
people to follow I think it will be
applied more consistently
represent Prue
so we just had a question of whether
this is going to cost more or not but in
my head and I'm asking you whether you
agree with me or not there's the
question
um
if they don't get released after the
third time and they've been known to
go out five times as two more uh
arraignment hearings that don't have to
happen because they're in jail until
these other cases are taken care of
would you agree to that I most certainly
do to give an exact a specific answer on
what the fiscal impact would be no way
to actually determine that but I think
there's a lot of
administrative and savings and Community
Savings especially on the law
enforcement side and the court side
that's often gets overlooked
and wouldn't you agree that community be
would be safer if that drunk driver was
off the road after the third time
permanently until he gets addressed
instead of two more times
and yes
thank you
um
representative Adams I have a question
um do you have
or a number of any idea how often this
would actually I mean how often do do we
know how and people who have been
arrested a fourth time while on bail is
is there any examples of this actually
happening
well I did give the drunk driving
example that was one and that was again
that was five times in a two-month time
period it does happen a lot you know
with drug offenses it happens a lot with
domestic violence offenses
so you're dealing with people who you
know it's not just the substance abuse
it's that that person is more likely to
commit you know breaking enterings
robbery stuff like that so you have
other high-level offenses that are um
sometimes the byproduct untreated mental
health issues but at the same time if
we're not gonna if we're gonna let the
person out to their own Peril we're not
necessarily doing them any favors so
there are some benefits of having a
person in a crisis and not letting them
harm themselves or others so there is
some other benefits of this policy
so you know further questions oh is
there aside that again
I don't know whether this is in order
but if I may let me say this I don't
think I'm required here but out under
ethics to say that I'm a bail
commissioner I will under the next bill
252. but I'll say it anyway I do I up to
I've done it for 22 years I'm up to
about 3 300 Bales I see one a year
of this
that is somebody violating failed
conditions that have before their trial
about one a year
I can say in my humble opinion I've I've
seen it not necessarily in courts in
this state but I've sat in courthouses
watching multiple and I've represented
individuals who violated their bail by
getting arrested for the same offense
and
managed to argue with successful bail
hearing by having that person released
again so I've seen it happen
several times and I've heard about it
happening several times and I read about
it and um I would watch other hearings
that I'm not involved in so I've seen it
happen and not necessarily in the state
but it does happen and I think having
this policy this way
creates a clear policy and it's
happening more in some of the higher
crime areas specifically Manchester and
Nashville is where this happens uh more
frequently High higher populated areas
representative
thank you just one quick question
um I'm sorry if this was already covered
but can you speak to the first paragraph
of the fiscal note where the judicial
branch says that
um that the way that this bill is
written is unclear to them
that they don't know how to
enforce it
I believe the judicial branch will be
here so you can ask them that question
since they I don't think that he can
really speak to them unless you can
represent Senator Evans so I think the
the problem is is that the law there is
a rebuttable presumption on the existing
law it's just it's not being applied
correctly or consists on consistently
but it also
the other problem you're having is even
if you have that rebuttable presumption
the law is not clearly expressing what
happens in order for you to rebut that
presumption what needs to be done and
what would happen if you do or don't so
even if you don't rebut the presumption
people are being still being released
so it seems to be applied differently uh
depending on where where you're getting
your case heard
I promise I
promise I'm dragging this out
the if you look at the paragraph It's
specifically confused about
how to implement
um when
when certain
activities need to occur that they're
saying
that they don't understand
I mean they're here right so maybe they
can just speak to that but it seems like
they're saying that they don't
understand like which arrest
um and that it's specifically like a
wording issue with the bill I don't know
so what what's written there is they're
not clear about what happens with the
second offense the second offense has to
still be open
so if you if you read this as it's
written
so if this problem cause to believe that
a person well on release pending a
resolution for prior offense so you have
that's your first
all right then if you go to the next
part it says they committed the felony
Class A misdemeanor
what um or drunk driving
while released unveiled thereafter was
arrested for a third felony so you're
talking about your first offense you've
now been arrested two more times
so it says third offense so I can't not
sure if you how to explain that
any clearance your third offense based
on being released on the first that's
okay we'll get the the court we'll
explain what their thinking was
um
so you know further questions thank you
representative uh Senator Abbas excuse
me
thank you
chair uh calls David Rothstein
good morning uh my name is David
Rothstein I was a public defender for
over 30 years I was one of the directors
of the program and I am now in private
practice and Exeter focusing largely on
criminal defense and I'm here on behalf
of the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers having listened
to uh the senator and to the questions
that the committee's already asked I
think really covered
primarily the points that I was going to
make so I'll be even briefer than five
minutes first of all I do believe in
response to a couple of of the questions
that the language already exists in the
present statute even with a second uh
offense
for example the language in this present
statute is if you are released on bail
and there's probable cause to believe
that while released you committed
another offense there is already the
mechanism the Machinery to do exactly
what this bill would would call for on a
second offense so obviously it would be
applied to a third offense or a fourth
offense so this statute has become
very complicated with a lot of different
provisions and a lot of different
um
permutations and if it if the language
already exists and is clear which I
believe it is I don't I don't see the
need for an amendment
um on top of that I would comment on
the language issue is one thing but I I
have spoken I think to a number of
familiar faces in another session I
think there are resource issues and in
this state that are very difficult to
get a hold of uh and a grip on one of
the resource issues that I've heard
before is sometimes a bail commissioner
doesn't know
the whole situation when somebody has
been rearrested so that's an information
situation that has to be addressed at
the local level there's uh J-1 which a
lot of people have access to in terms of
getting information
um so that's that's not an issue that
this statute can address there are also
issues on the setting of bail and
getting enough information about the
person that you have before you when you
set bail when I was here before I talked
about how short notice you have when
somebody's rearrested you have to hold
one of these hearings the prosecutor the
judge the defense attorney don't know
very much about the person if you have a
county where there's pre-trial Services
where they can do an interview of the
person before the bail hearing like in
the federal system you get a lot more
information about the person they can
run a record on the person they can try
to confirm some of their information
this happens in some counties it doesn't
happen in others but again that's an
implementation issue rather than a
language issue and finally in response
to I believe one of the the questions
there is a need for flexibility even in
a repeated arrest scenario now I have a
different perspective on repeated
arrests from my perspective if I'm
representing somebody who's been out on
bail commits one new offense commits two
new offenses it's going to be very very
difficult from my perspective as a
practical matter to get that person
released again on bail however there are
still individual circumstances to take
into account if the person is getting
rearrested for a violent offense if the
person is getting arrested for
escalating offenses the chances of them
being released and I know you've had an
opportunity to talk to some judges are
incredibly incredibly slim as a
practical matter however most of the new
offenses that people get released on are
not violent mostly you do not have the
five DWIs or five armed robberies and
people getting released and committing
new offenses it's usually attributable
to substance use disorder and mental
health issues and to put people in jail
for potentially a very long time is not
the best solution the jails are not
outfitted to help people these people
are going to be released the jails are
not outfitted to get these people what
they need so that when they get back
into the community they're less likely
to reoffend
in some counties there is an active
pre-trial release program where people
actually connect with the person and
they figure out what they need and they
supervise them in the community and they
can get them into long-term drug
treatment they can get them into mental
health treatment
the state is a a great place but it's so
variable County to county that in some
counties like in Hillsborough County our
biggest County where there's probably
the most crime and the most serious
crime we don't have that type of program
I think that again I think it's not so
much a language issue as it is an
implementation issue and while I
understand certainly the point that the
senator made quite a valid point quite
frustrating when somebody gets
rearrested I do think the language here
already exists and the energy should be
put into trying to develop
implementation resources so that people
are less likely to reoffend and I'd be
glad to take any questions
representative Bolden
thanks for taking my question maybe it's
not in your wheelhouse
um I know that about half this committee
represents Hillsborough County
um do you know if someone is in the
example of five DUIs if they're taken to
County Jail are there um services
available at Hillsborough County for
them
yeah Hillsborough County is historically
it's obviously the biggest jail in the
state because it serves the biggest
population
historically in in my view it is
chronically
the one of the least capable of
taking people in and providing them
certainly pre-trial resources there is
no pre-trial release program in
Hillsborough County as there is in
Merrimack County Stratford County and I
believe Cheshire county I think I think
a program like that in Hillsborough
County would be would be fantastic if it
existed but you know we're talking about
you're talking about County government I
think I think it's very hard for you
know for for a statute or for the state
to force a county to develop these these
programs
represent Pro
you talked about the language is
available at the second one yes but it's
not mandatory it's not
it's a it but it creates it's not
mandatory uh uh representative proof but
I I believe it's reasonably
a mirror image of the proposed language
except
I think you can do it the the second
time as well if you're if if it as I
read it if you are on release pending
resolution of a prior offense and you
commit a felony Class A misdemeanor or
driving or operating on impaired there
shall be a rebuttable presumption that
the person will not be about abide and
that means the result of that is if you
don't need the rebuttal pool presumption
then you can be detained I agree with
you that this third offense language is
more
directive and I I think the senator
talks about the importance of trying to
perpetuate a a policy I I don't think I
don't think that anyone including the
judges you you met disagree with the
fact that if someone comes on a second
offense or third offense or more that
it's highly highly likely the person is
going to be detained as a practical
matter
so
I know in my city
it was a revolving door so they weren't
using the second one
or the third one or the fourth one
so I think then I'm all set for putting
in mandatory to the second one if I
thought it would pass right
but I'm kind of liking the at least the
third one they need to be held and right
and I understand there's other programs
that they can go into
and maybe being held they can get put
into those programs
would I agree
seeing none uh thank you
thanks for taking my question if if um
if mental health and drug issues are
are really the root cause of a lot of
the the reoffensives that we're seeing
and we passed this bill
so we're in a situation where we're not
only holding more people pre-detension
but a lot of the people that we're
holding are problematic from you know
from a drug in a mental health
standpoint you said that there's a lot
of variability uh between the counties
and how these cases are treated what
about the help that somebody can
actually get while they're behind bars
can they get any
well they really can't I mean I I can
relate a story I had with somebody who
had serious uh mental health issues very
serious mental health issues that
rendered him
um incompetent and the jail said in
terms of mental health issues
you know we offer very limited like you
know once a week they can talk to a
counselor uh it's all voluntary
their their view on mental health is
that if the person's mental health
issues are not disrupting the facility
in other words if they're not creating a
safety concern in the jail then I mean
they really don't become proactive in
terms of trying to involve that person
in mental health counseling so the
person is you know is is sitting in in a
jail I think any of us even those of us
who hopefully have
good mental health and don't suffer from
from substance use issues would decline
significantly if we were incarcerated if
we were separated from our community and
if we were
um probably already untreated when we
entered the jail the jails are the jails
I think do by and large a very good job
at what they're designed to do they are
not designed to serve the function of
providing rehabilitative services to
people who struggle with chronic mental
health issues or substance use issues I
have heard that the jail if you're in
withdrawal I've heard it's just a
terrible place to be if you're trying if
you're going through the withdrawal
symptoms and you're in jail they just
don't they just don't have the resources
what they have done over time is they
have been able to get into giving
medically assisted treatment to people
who qualify and that can help some
people but mental illness is a real I
think if you went to the jail and you'd
talk to people you would find
just a stunning amount of mental illness
substance use disorder and also
comorbidity the two coming together
representative Newman
yeah just to have a quick question my
concern about this is the uh taking
discretion away from judges and bail
commissioners
and one of my concerns is according to
the way I read the bill
all three of the all of three of the
offenses that they may have been bailed
on
could have been I don't want to say
low-level offenses for driving while
intoxicated I mean it could be they all
did .12 or whatever the current level is
or just above that
somebody that maybe has a problem but
not a really significant problem and and
use misjudgment
and got him him or herself arrested a
third time is there a potential here
that we could unknowingly unwittingly
and unwantedly
affecting those kind of people
who have not been
convicted of anything
um more so even or more people even than
how many are affected by the fourth
fifth sixth seventh uh offense kind of
person
um I just believe that the judges and
the bail Commissioners with the rules
the way they're written now have the
ability do you agree with that I I do
agree representative I think that that
you know we have to by and large trust
the people who have
um the local knowledge the people who
are the judges the people who are the
prosecutors to make those decisions I
think by and large they make good
decisions as I said if I am going to
court and I am representing somebody
who's a recidivist uh in this situation
I'm going to do what I can as a defense
attorney my ethical obligation is to if
they want to be released and try to
argue for their release I will tell you
on one hand that that's very very
difficult to do if someone is a repeat
offender is a practical matter but on
the other hand I do think that amount of
discretion
is is very important and I do think we
should trust the people at the local
level to to by and large make those
decisions
thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair recognizes Frank Knack
from the ACLU
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire
um we will have a handout for the next
bill I don't on this bill in part
because we are still not 100 sure what
the what the bill is trying to do I
think we heard um the senator talk about
the fact that this is really just trying
to create after the third offense but if
you look and I think there was questions
about this if you look at how this
language is drafted quote the person
shall be detained in pre-trial detention
based on a relatable presumption that
the person shall be detained is new
language that doesn't exist anywhere
else that I've seen in the Bell statute
so if you look at for example the
failure appear section the rebuttable
presumption is just that there shall be
a rebuttable presumption but not that
the person shall be detained and so this
really makes us think that this is a
backdoor three strikes law completely
taking judicial discretion
out of the statue and again we're also
concerned that the pr bail option so
that we are not having a two-tiered
criminal legal system where people with
wealth can pay for their freedom where
people without wealth cannot
um has been shipped from this
um
uh just a few other things that I want
to touch on
um is you know as you know we are in
very uh great really appreciate and huge
support of chairman Roy's addition to
the budget around getting the funding in
there to have a real-time Bill tracking
system again we see no data that there's
actually an issue Happening Here with
people being released we've heard
anecdotes but we have no hard data and
so having this real-time system in place
would ensure that if anyone making these
important decisions has all that
information in real time so that if
someone's being released and getting
rearrested that person making that
decision has that information in real
time we think that's an important step
forward and one that does so without
unnecessarily taking anyone's Liberty
just making sure that we have all the
information in place
um again I I imagine Professor Cheryl
will talk about this but we also have to
can't ignore the fact that the data that
he has collected shows that 36 percent
of the cases that they looked at the
cases the charges were later dismissed
or null and so this notion that you know
everyone who's getting arrested is
guilty first of all that's not how our
criminal legal system works and second
of all that's not how it's working
practically in New Hampshire 36 percent
of the cases they looked at were later
dismissed or null Prost and so the fact
that people are going to be
automatically detained and taken having
their Liberty taken away is is troubling
um and finally I think just kind of
getting back to the public safety angle
and again we'll talk about this on the
next bill but there's a huge amount of
research on this issue and so when we
hear individuals talking about the fact
that we need this to increase Public
Safety the research says the opposite so
there may be specific cases and that's
why judicial discretion is important
while someone should be detained based
on this specific facts in that case and
letting the court make that
determination having these blankets
whole of rules that people shall be
detained goes against all the research
on this issue because you're going to be
pulling people away from their
communities their job their
responsibilities if they have child care
or they're caring for elderly parents
there's Myriad rays that people that the
harms will just exacerbate if we're
unnecessarily detaining people and I
apologize we didn't have daycare today
so this is my son
um
so I thank you and happy to answer any
questions
fill out a pink card oh I'll have him do
that
any questions uh representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I was wondering you know a lot of
what this sounds like to me is
um you know of course we're making it
mandatory and of course to me that
reminds me of mandatory minimums I would
assume that that's kind of what you're
talking about the research as far as
when we take the discretion away and do
that kind of stuff I was wondering if
you could speak a little bit to that
um you know I won't
you share my own my own story of the
impact of mandatory minimums on on my
life but uh it was very very destructive
as far as I'm concerned and so I'm I'm
curious especially where that coincides
with things like mental health and
substance use and I'm sure you know from
the ACLU you have probably a lot of
information I was wondering if you could
expand on that a little bit yeah
absolutely you know that a little bit
beyond what I was planning on talking
about today so I can definitely send you
all tons of research on the harms of
mandatory minimums in the sentencing
phase
um not in the pre-trial phase but again
with that you know we saw that Evolution
really started in the early 80s and kind
of perpetuate
um the you know the fact that we now are
I think five percent of the world's
population 25 percent of the world's
incarcerated population in part because
of mandatory minimums and three strikes
laws
um and that we're seeing States across
the country including deep red states in
the South move away from that because
they've seen that they have net harms on
the community and if there were actually
concerned about having safer communities
I'm ensuring that you know the vast
majority of people are going to be
released that we're ensuring that when
people are released um you know we've
had proper Rehabilitation and we have
proper services in place
um that there's been a move away from
that but in this pre uh pre-trial phase
that that we're concerned with here
um it's even it's even more concerning
because these people are not convicted
of anything they're alleged to have done
certain things there's research that we
have from New Hampshire that shows that
more than one in three people will have
those charges later dismissed and
they'll Prost and so we're concerned
with kind of anything that takes away
that judicial discretion for the court
to look at all the facts to look at the
person as an individual and say I think
this person is a danger or a Flight Risk
and detain them which they have multiple
ways of doing right now under the law or
to say I do not think this person is a
danger or a Flight Risk and therefore
give them release and as has been
pointed out there are multiple ways in
the current bail law where people can be
detained if they break their release
orders if a prosecutor disagrees with
the chart with a release decision
there's Myriad ways that they can be
um health
thanks
representative Bolden
um what is your son's name uh Felix I
have a follow-up though
um Hi Felix
um as far as the use that this sort of
re-implements the three strikes law I I
think I understand that that's some
Clinton administration concept do you
know if there's any
Research into the concept of having
three strikes you're out outside of like
how it affects baseball
um I can definitely send you all lots of
information on that
um actually a lot of the origins of the
three strikes laws unfortunately came
from the privatization of our prisons
and so uh the private prison providers
CCA Geo others at the time were actually
pushing these model three strikes laws
across the country because it was good
for business it was a way for them to
ensure that they had more people in
their beds they actually in their um
their financial disclosures that they're
required to disclose way back would
actually talk about you know their
concerns with efforts to move away from
this and how it was going to impact
their bottom line and so fortunately New
Hampshire we have not gone down that
route of private facilities but that one
of the major you know origin and kind of
the major pushes across the country of
these laws not in a pre-trial but in the
incred in the in the sentencing phase
was the private prison facilities
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair
um
this bill and where where it says that
um while on bail I'm just curious about
personal recognizance in bail are would
they be considered the same in this bill
or would somebody on personal
recognizance get an extra strike or how
how do you think that might work
I I don't think that there would be a
distinction there I think our concern
here though is this this is taking out
PR bail as an option so that you're
going to striking out that section so
that people without wealth are now going
to be detained because they're going to
have cash bail that they can't afford
and so the people with wealth will just
pay the fee and or pay the bill and and
get released thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
so much
the chair recognizes uh chief profansky
morning Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for having me today
my name is John burfonski I'm currently
the chief of police in Bedford New
Hampshire where I've been chief for
um more than 11 years I have 45 years in
law enforcement experience and currently
the president of New Hampshire Chiefs of
Police Association ladies and gentlemen
of the committee
if the current bail system was working
appropriately and properly I wouldn't be
here today Senator Abbas would not be
sponsoring this bill today if the
implementation of the bail system here
in the granite state was working to
protect victims
that word victim I don't think has been
mentioned in this room for the past hour
why aren't we talking about victims here
the victims of crime
the people that whether they're low
level or not if your loved one happens
to be a victim of crime it's not a low
level offense
they're a victim
right
in the 45 years and my police experience
I can tell you without
any equivocation that the majority of
crime is committed at all levels by a
small disproportionate number of
offenders
that's been the Axiom in the Criminal
Justice System since I was an
undergraduate in criminology and
penology in 1973 50 years ago taught by
the commissioner Corrections for the
state of Connecticut
disproportionate number of crime is com
the majority of crime is committed by a
disproportionate number of offenders
prolific offenders are responsible for
the vast majority of crime everywhere
here in this state as well as across the
country included in my written testimony
there is a recent study that was
completed in Seattle
where they implemented a system over a
year ago
to focus on prolific repeat offenders
and lo and behold what they found was
that by doing so they reduced crime
overall in the city of Seattle
another study which is not included but
I can get it to you if you want it from
California shows precisely the impact of
focusing on repeat offenders that are
continually releasing the system over
and over again who have reoffended
there's been a lot of talk about the
percentages of crime and the percentages
and numbers of arrests
Bedford New Hampshire does approximately
700 arrests a year talking with my
colleague Chief Oldenburg who's in the
room between Bedford and Manchester we
arrest somewhere around the vicinity of
5 000 people a year
for Bedford alone I've been a chief
during the time there's probably been on
over 70 000 arrests and I look at each
and every one and I have done so for the
past 11 years and I can tell you
that when we talk about the catch and
release system that's precisely what it
is
it's become such a mockery that in the
criminal justice system the equivalent
of a tank of gas or two bags of heroin
get you out of jail
and that's what happens each and every
day across the state to the point where
Manchester cops and Bedford cops
Troopers and sheriffs know the names of
these people
they know where they live they know how
many times that they've been arrested
and they can tell you their criminal
history like it's on the back of their
hand why because they run across them so
many times this is a bill that focuses
on prolific repeat offenders
right you can draw the line at two you
can draw the line at three you can draw
a line at four but the line hasn't been
drawn at all because we're talking about
people that are in and out of jail 12 13
14 15 times I know one case in Bedford
at least 17 times where this person's
been arrested and released
uh reoffending each time under bail
conditions
it's past time that we take some action
and to think about the victims of crime
the victims of crime victims of crime
can we think about the victims of crime
once
when we talk about these types of bills
there's people out there that are
suffering each and every day at the
hands of these people
I'm not talking about the retailers and
the shoplifting crime that's perpetrated
in lows or Target whatever we're talking
about the trades person
that loses their life's ability to work
when their truck is stolen
or their tools are stolen
or that some person is working three
jobs to try to make ends meet to put
food on the table and the catalytic
converter is cut off their car and it's
a two thousand dollar job that they
can't pay for
that's what we're talking about here
it's high time past time that we think
about the victims of crime thank you Mr
chair
representative Noel
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I appreciate that a lot you know
reminding us to think about the victims
of the crime Mike my question I guess is
you know the way that it sounds there's
already the discretion to be able to
detain people if if that's seen as
necessary so if there's something but
that would be at the discretion of the
judge and so my question is
are is what you're saying that that the
judge is not considering the victims
the judge isn't considering the victims
the system isn't considering the victims
because there is no consequence right uh
yes that's precisely the fact I look at
every single Minimus that comes from the
Hillsborough County Attorney's Office to
the man to the Bedford Police Department
every single day right and the vast
majority of those people are are people
that have been arrested and reoffended
in what world doesn't make any sense to
arrest someone for failure to appear and
then let them out again
on our war and to reoffend
it's an accident it's true that the
majority of offenders right commit a
disproportionate amount of crime and
that's been true for many many decades
we need to focus on the people that
continue to reoffend if we can do that
you will have less costs in the criminal
justice system you will have less
resource costs on the courts you will
have less costs for the police
departments and the prosecutors and the
public defenders because these cases
weren't happening and trust me when I
tell you offenders if this law goes into
effect and offenders know that they hit
the third strike law right or the third
strike and they're going to go to Valley
Street jail
they're going to be thinking twice about
committing a third offense
thank you
scitec
Chief Uh something's getting blurred
here
we're talking about pre-trial the
instances I see of long rap sheets are
people who have committed a new crime
after their previous has crime has been
adjudicated
are you confusing conflating two
situations one of pre-trial and one of a
new offense after adjudication and I I
this is it sounds slippery to me
well let me put some sand on the
slippery slope there is no conflating of
the two issues well I'm talking about
people that we know that have been
released on bail conditions failure to
appear and other crimes that are
continually out reoffend out reoffend
and none of those cases have been
adjudicated takes a year year and a half
two years for some of these cases to go
through and some of the other testimony
when we talk about non-profit no process
the vast majority of those no processes
that I get in Bedford are part of what
we call the global plea a certain crime
that was indicted for example or a
complaint is null Prost in favor of a
plea to combine charges sometimes
between two towns or two cities so
oftentimes the people that we arrest
happen to be the same people that are
arrested in Manchester and then there's
a global plea in Superior Court where
the Bedford charges non-profits in favor
of the other charges in Manchester
so be careful when you look at numbers
because numbers can be deceiving
if isn't it true that even within one
town
several charges can be null crossed in
favor of one particular charge that is
pled to
100 that's exactly what happens
representative Bolden
I understand your concerns about
um
people who are being victimized
is it not the case that many if not most
of our drug laws in New Hampshire are
misdemeanors which would be included
under this legislation and wouldn't we
be capturing people
with this bill who need drug treatment
and maybe aren't being arrested for
victimizing anyone
um other than destroying their own lives
was the baby that just died in
Manchester a victimless crime that was a
drug crime
that's not a victimless crime
um so let me ask you let me ask you uh
answer your question
we would love in law enforcement to have
services in every single jail in every
single county in the state of New
Hampshire
where people that are arrested for
property crime who have an underlying
substance use disorder could get
treatment the study that you're seeing
in Seattle shows that for the vast
majority of people that are released
they don't seek treatment
that's a fact the vast majority of
people that are released don't seek
treatment
but if they're arrested and if they have
an underlying substance use disorder
and if we had effective programs and
there are effective programs that are
out there
that cut recidivism significantly the
main State Prison Maine just introduced
a medically assisted treatment program
in Maine in a prison system a couple of
years ago that has shown pretty good
results if we had that in our County
jails right we would have
an opportunity to address this
particular problem whereas when people
are released
they go back to reoffending and they
don't show up at trema
I'm sorry if I put you on the defensive
how my question was worded I think what
I was trying to get at was would you
object to changing this the wording to
be more specific about
the types of offenses that would apply
so that we're not capturing people who
would be
at a disadvantage if they're
incarcerated seeing as it sounds like at
least in Hillsborough County it'd be
extraordinarily difficult to access
treatment while incarcerated there so my
question is would you object to making
changes to specify
um criminal offenses that actually
involve victimizing others
yes I would because those are the people
that are sticking out on the convenience
stores on Pine Street
right those are victims uh and so we
start drawing the line and the squiggly
line and gerrymandering different crimes
we're not getting the effect that's
necessary there needs to be a strong
message from you to the uh to these
offenders and to a strong message to the
victims of crime in your cons in your
constituencies that this has to stop
Chief the the crimes you talked about
the property crimes
um you know the stealing of the tools
the catalytic converters is that not
most of the time to support to pay for
their drug addictions is that not the
the origin of those crimes most of the
time a lot of the level property crime
yes absolutely Mr chair as a result of
substance abuse disorder and the fact of
the matter is is that when those people
are released right without any effective
treatment right despite the fact that
there are bail conditions they continue
to reoffend most of the time to support
their substance use disorder right but
where we have programs in place
Rockingham County I believe has a fairly
um
well-run program that addresses
substance use disorder in their jail and
it's effective
but if we release them we lose control
over the ability to make sure that they
get the treatment that they need to stop
the behavior that society believes is
not what they should be doing
as a follow-up what is your experience
with our current drug court system
my experience is that it's not very
effective and the reason why it's not
very effective is because again there's
no consequences right if there's no
consequence to not adhering to the
conditions by which the court sets then
the individual continues on a path and a
trajectory
that is consistent with what brought
them there in the first place so I would
say that while drug courts may be
effective they need to be coupled with a
more effective
program of
Services as well as a more effective
program of treatment
to the extent that if the individual
who violates the terms and conditions
set by the drug court judge
then the next step has to be a confined
treatment program in a facility that
will cost money
it will cost a lot of money
but at the end of the day it's going to
be less money
than what's being suffered each and
every day each and every year
by the victims of crime in the granite
state
they can't representative Newell
did I just ask a really quick clarify
clarification because you mentioned
medically assisted treatment I was I was
very involved in changing the rules
around buprenorphines commonly known as
Suboxone and so that it's easier to
prescribe and access and things like
that and we did hear when we were going
through our orientation that from the
Department of Corrections that it that's
a very helpful thing that's going to be
implemented in the state prisons and I'm
just on the state level and I'm just
curious when you say that uh you know
medically assisted treatment you're
talking about in Maine are you saying
that in on the county level uh there is
not necessarily access to medically
assisted treatments such as
buprenorphine and things like that
um anecdotally do I have proof in front
of me no but my my senses is that there
are insufficient effective programs
whether they're medically assisted
treatment programs or other programs for
people in jail
um that have an underlying substance use
disorder unfortunately thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chair
and I apologize to any members that I
had for the questions but we do have to
move this one along
um the chair recognizes uh Professor
share
good morning uh my name is uh Buzz sure
I'm a professor of law at UNH law and a
elected Police Commissioner in
Portsmouth
my opinions today are mine only they're
not those of unh law UNH or the
Portsmouth police commission or Police
Department
um
let me address a few things that have
already been said and then get to the
point of my testimony one a bail is can
be in three different forms it can be
personal cognizance bail PR bail it can
be cash bail where you need to put up an
amount of cash or it could be corporate
charity where you need to put up some
sort of security and pay usually about
10 percent of uh of what your bail is so
those all count as bail be it bail or
whether it's called bail or PR
um
uh
I've said this before and I'm going to
continue to say it because uh it it it
wrinkles me
the term catch and release is a term
that refers to fish
it does not refer to human beings and to
talk about human beings in terms of
catch and release is inappropriate and
offensive
uh all the people who are involved in
the Criminal Justice System including
those who are charged with crimes are
actually human beings
and have complicated lives and so we
need to respect all of them whether we
like their conduct or not and whether we
approve of their conduct or not so
um I I will continue to make that point
as people continue to use that term
the chief statement that there are no
consequences for drug court and problems
in drug court is just flat out wrong
um I recommend that this committee talk
to the judges the Superior Court judges
who run drug courts and find out that
there are consequences if you fail in
drug court drug court does involve
requirements of treatment of counseling
that's the whole point of drug court to
deal with situations in a way different
than just sending people to the state
prison and letting them further descend
into uh repeat crimes uh in the criminal
justice system that's the whole idea
behind drug court and uh I would ask the
chief if he doesn't understand that to
talk to Chief Justice Neto of the
Superior Court who has managed drug
Courts for a number of years they are
very effective
if only we could have more resources to
deal with them
finally on the issue of nullpross to
address something the chair brought up
of having several charges in one town uh
and them getting no Pros for for uh in
return for a plea on one of them
the documents that we looked at from the
court system they're called case summary
sheets
uh if an incident leads to a number of
different charges they're all on one
case summary sheet and so if there's a
plea to one of those charges or to a
lesser of those charges that would be
reflected on the case summary sheet so I
don't think it's the case that the huge
majority
or even a small majority of the null
process that we saw in 36 percent of the
504 cases we looked at are because of
plea Bargains you know I've talked with
the public defender program about that
I've talked with a number of lawyers
there's just a lot of overcharging
and there's no way around that
um part of the overcharging is because
the system in New Hampshire is not well
designed for a lot of consultation
between prosecutors and police before
the formal charging happens it's a more
of a back-end system than a front-end
system
uh and so I I think you end up with a
good bit of overcharging
um so I
as this committee knows from my
testimony other circumstances I care
about actual data uh and I think this
committee needs to make decisions based
on real data not just anecdote I don't
think it's it makes sense for this
committee to decide what to do with this
bill based on the five DWI example
that's a rare occurrence
the the there there's several issues in
terms of a lack of data one there is
really I think
in reality in the bail system two two
separate categories of people uh
identified uh in the current system and
the uh the the proposal by Senator Abbas
one Those who commit felonies and are
out on bail and uh are then charged with
another crime
or a third crime
that group of people as uh attorney uh
restein testified that just not very
frequently are those people gonna be
released
on the second offense let alone the
third offense it's just not very common
the only reason it's common
it the only reason it happens is if
because a prosecutor doesn't bring a
motion to revoke bail on the original
felony
some of you may have read in uh
editorial an op-ed piece I wrote in the
Manchester Union leader about a really
tragic homicide case in Manchester where
the individual was out on bail on an
attempted first degree assault
uh he committed another misdemeanor in
early August and a set of misdemeanors
in later August early September in
neither of those instances uh the the
the uh did the courts set bail that
resulted in being held and he then is
later charged with uh killing somebody
in those two courts in the court hearing
were those two misdemeanor sets
subsequent to the first degree assault
bail release
the prosecutor didn't even bring up the
fact that the defendant was out on first
attempted first degree murder bail
the problem with that circumstance
was not the bail statute which
completely capable of holding that
person after those two sets of
subsequent misdemeanors but the
prosecutor in each of those misdemeanor
sets didn't even bring up
that he was out on Bayon attempted first
degree murder and second the prosecutor
on the attempted first degree assault
didn't move in that case to revoke Veil
because of the two subsequent
misdemeanors sets of misdemeanors so
that's a prosecutorial favor
and I think with the felonies
um where somebody's out on bail on a
felony and subsequent offenses are
occurred uh they're either getting held
or prosecutors are just not bringing it
to the attention of the Court not a
failure of the bail statute a failure uh
of in that instance prosecutorial
Behavior the second set of crimes that's
kind of buried in the current statute
and and and the changes is Class A
misdemeanors
now Class A misdemeanors can be
shoplifting can be disorderly conduct
uh uh can be Petty crimes
under this statute if you commit three
if you are out on bail on PR bail on a
petty crime a disorderly conduct kind of
yelling in public and you do that two
more times uh before your original
charges arrested this would
automatically mean you go to jail
I don't think we want this to work that
way
that's more of a street sweeping bail
statute than it is something to deal
with uh real issues
more importantly let me go back to my
notes
um
we don't know how many of the first kind
of uh uh felony followed by two
subsequent arrests how many of those are
there are out there whether the problem
that Senator Abbas uh and the chief and
others describe is a really significant
problem or not we just don't have any
data and we can't make keep making
decisions without data based on this
based on anecdote
um
what's left out is really telling what's
left out from the way the statute is now
to what is proposed are two things one
the language that uh you can't you can't
hold somebody based on a financial
condition without the court determining
by clear and convincing evidence that
there's no reasonable alternatives
the true failure bar any other comments
that have been made of Senator abbas's
proposal is it's unconstitutional
U.S versus Salerno says if you're going
to hold somebody
without bail
as Senator Abbas proposal
recommends regardless of the
circumstance you have to have a hearing
he has to be the individual has to be
represented by counsel
and there has to be a burden that the
state has to prove by clear and
convincing evidence that they are
dangerous you can't do it with just the
rebuttable presumption it's
unconstitutional
um and and I think that's the Fatal flaw
uh with this bill
um
I think I'm almost done uh last
I think
slowly but surely we're making progress
on the issue of bail and bail reform and
how the system should work
I know uh representative representative
Harriet gathright has had a proposal for
magistrate judges and that was turned
into a study committee which is making
its way through the sis the the
legislative system I'm very optimistic
about that I know represent the chair
has uh has gotten into uh the budget a
proposal for funding for a real-time
bail situation so prosecutors know when
they look at a person arrested for
something whether immediately not days
later but immediately whether there is a
uh a pending when the person is already
out on bail those developments are very
promising and I know a number of uh bail
bills arising out of the house have been
retained in hopes of having a collective
Gathering and this and and uh process of
sorting out
what adjustments that we can what
adjustments can we make to the bail
system with all the stakeholders present
in that discussion not trying to deal
with it by one bill offered by a senator
another bill offered by a representative
another bill offered by a senator you
know individual tweaks here and there
let's look at it as a package let's have
all the stakeholders with roles in the
system and I think I think this
committee has done great work in hearing
from more and more people in visiting
jails and visiting the court system I
think that is the way to approach this
and we've made more progress in thinking
through how to reach good Solutions
without knowing exactly what the right
solution would be by the efforts that
have been made by representative Herod
gathright by representative Roy uh by
this Committee in retaining bills so I
am encourage this committee to retain
this bill looking at the time I'm not
sure I'm going to be here
for the next bill
you have heard my thoughts uh in terms
of this this the senator Susie's bill
which is very similar to uh
uh Senator Bradley's bill of last year
you've heard my thoughts you've all
received a copy of my study
that is ongoing I will point out that we
continue to increase the number of cases
we look at I think we're we're over a
thousand now we're seeing no appreciable
change in in the results of that study
um so um
I have strong hopes that if this bill
and the subsequent bill is retained we
can have
we can really think well
with input from everybody
how to manage the concerns such as they
are with the bail bill as it currently
exists uh thank you for listening to me
once again
oh representative Manion
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned us
talking about the data so I'm this
question is about the data of the 504
cases that you cited and was also
mentioned by the gentleman from the ACLU
of those 504 cases
how many were
on a person who is out on bail two times
prior for felonies Class A misdemeanors
or DUI charges
then gets arrested a third time for a
similar offense
had all of those cases non-processed
we could not uh look at that because we
were limited by the case summary sheet
we were looking at and the case summary
sheet only has on it those which the
person is charged with in that incident
so it's an incident by incident case
summary sheet it doesn't include in it
other subsequent or previous charges
from other incidents so we have no way
of and we have no way of tracking that
through the case summary sheet so I I
can't answer the question I'd like to
answer the question but that's too
complicated uh a data collection thing
unfortunately
thank you uh so that data would not
apply as far as this bill is concerned
ah yes and no thank you
uh no big yes uh it would apply because
some of those were
foundational charges might have been the
first felony uh that would count under
this bill or the second one or the third
one we just don't know that one way or
another no in that we can't track it as
you described
represent Prue
so I'm not a big data guy but that
sounds like flawed data to me if you
can't answer all those questions and see
all their previous
record
and what's pending on them
that's not data oh it it's data for what
we represented as we don't represent it
as a comprehensive study of of the kind
uh representative Manion uh I and I when
I testify to that study I represented it
just as what it was and I appreciate
that it's not perfect data it doesn't uh
it doesn't
um capture uh everything that's going on
in the system but uh to be fair
representative Prue I did not represent
it as a complete picture of what's going
on
um the problem is and this is for this
committee and other committees to solve
if they want true data complete data of
the type you want is you need to spend
millions of dollars to to uh so the
court system can purchase a data
collection system which Software System
which they don't have then we could get
the data that we all want but that has
not happened yet I've I've you know for
five years I have been arguing that we
need to do that to no avail
so you're asking me to make a decision
on this on your flawed data now one I
disagree with you uh on on it being
flawed data it's not flawed in what we
represent the data to be I'm not asking
you to make a decision based on this
bill based on that data
I I raised the issue of the study
because it had previously been been
raised by one of the prior Witnesses
representative um Cameron
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I found it very
interesting when you said
that a person that commits a petty theft
would be subject to this bill
if it's charged as a Class A yes
well I just looked up the statute if
it's less than a thousand dollars it's a
misdemeanor and that means that the
prosecutor has the wherewithal to CL in
charge of the Class B and you also said
that
um it would be unconstitutional because
they weren't they didn't have
representation while a Class A
misdemeanor requires representation
under our constitution so how do you
square that uh what I said was if they
didn't have representation and the
burden of proof was not clear and
convincing the you need both those
things uh the the statute proposed the
amendment proposed by Senator Abbotts
eliminates the clear and convincing
standard of proof that's what's
unconstitutional about it uh number one
number two some prosecutors choose to
charge uh a petty theft as a Class A
some choose to charge it as a Class B
many prosecutors choose to charge it as
a Class B so the person won't have
counsel
thank you for your testimony professor
and the chair recognizes attorney head
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch judicial branch has
no position on the policy of this bill
and that's not the point of my comments
today I did want to address one of the
thought one of the issues that was
identified in our fiscal note which was
an ability to interpret some of the
language in the bill and I've spoken
briefly with with Senator Abbas about
this as you run through the bill
it's essentially a three strikes bill so
in the first part of it says if there's
probable cause to believe that a person
while on release uh pending resolution
of a previous offense committed a Class
A misdemeanor or driving or operating
while impaired and then it goes on to
say was released on bail and thereafter
was arrested it does not repeat that
same language about release pending
resolution of a previous offense so it
simply said is essentially on the third
offense thereafter after the first two
offenses without tying without
affirmatively tying it to the other two
offenses and the status of the other two
offenses in our fiscal note
uh we wrote that we assumed that both of
those prior to offenses had to still be
active essentially at the time of the
third arrest
um and and based on on Senator abbas's
testimony I believe that was the intent
it could be
resolved by simply saying where it says
and thereafter on line 13 while on
release pending resolution of the prior
to offenses essentially reincorporate
that language into the bill
um would at least help clarify that
ambiguity
the other issue that creates some level
of ambiguity is that all of these rely
upon knowledge of the status of Baal at
the time of arrest and as as has been
commented on
um based on some of the work that
chairman Roy has done there is work
that's that's going forward hopefully
that will provide some information about
the status of bail when the bail is is
uh is issued
what happens though is that bail can
change over time or that a case is
resolved at a certain point in that I
don't believe would be tracked under
that system it's essentially a snapshot
of bail at the time bail was issued and
then thereafter you know an individual
the the status of that bail may not be
reflected in that same system it in the
same real time and I honestly don't know
the answer to that whether would or
wouldn't but I think that's a somewhat
more complicated system and as has been
noted we do not currently in the
judicial branch keep a real-time
database that is available to law
enforcement at the time of arrest that
would give the status of bail at the
time of arrest we do rely in in terms of
a of a court proceeding on the
prosecutor to bring forward the status
of any uh prior offenses that an
individual is is being presented to a
judge as it relates to a hearing before
a judge so I just want to make those two
points but make clear we do not have a
position on the on the policy of this
bill with that I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you
representative Bolden
I'm sorry Terry I just have a lot of
questions
um thanks for taking my question are you
I feel like what I'm hearing is that I
want to know if if I understand you
correctly that it's possible like it's
within the realm of possibility to be
um
if this passed to be incarcerated
um for bail violations after the case
has been resolved for which you were
under bail conditions like am I making
sense it sounds like because of the
limitations of data and tracking cases
that you could be
um
in trouble for violating bail conditions
that no longer apply you know I think so
thank you for the question I think it's
more likely to occur the other way which
is a person would not be held in
detention because the time of the third
arrest they may not know the status of
the other two bail proceedings so I I I
think the risk is greater in the other
direction which is
um the person would not be detained on
the third rest because the con the
status of the prior to arrest may not be
known at the time
thanks for that that helped me
understand a lot so it's not that
someone might go to jail when they
really shouldn't is that they won't go
to jail when they should under the
current status of things I think that's
the the more likely scenario based upon
the lack of information about the status
of bail at the time of arrest
thank you
thank you Mr chair
so what what you were just talking about
the the information would not be
available
um do we need to fix the information
problems so that the judges and the
prosecutors and whoever has the
discretion makes better discretion than
trying to Jerry rig the law around all
the time to cover all the consequences
and maybe catch people and I'm not going
to use the rest of that analogy
um that have never committed a crime and
they've just got three arrests and they
according to the way we have now changed
the law they get caught in that
situation do you does that make any
sense to you
um yes so thank you for the question and
I think one I think the chairman has
taken a significant first step towards
getting information I do believe having
that level of of
immediately available information to law
enforcement at the time of rest is an
important aspect of of the system what
it would take though is a considerable
level of resources both in terms of
technology that would be at the court
system and communicating outside of the
court system and unfortunately Personnel
because
there are a large number of bail
decisions being made daily and and to be
able to input bail decisions into a
system immediately such that it is
thereafter immediately available takes
human resources to be able to monitor
bail decisions as they're being made in
real time and input that into a system
in real time and then have that system
immediately accessible and it's a it is
a complicated certainly a doable but it
would require a large number of human
resources and in technology that we
currently sort of wouldn't be able to
implement immediately
thank you
representative salic
thank you Mr chair so I just want to
make sure I understand the full
implications so if I were hypothetically
a young college student
during pledge week who was not of age to
drink alcohol what got myself very drunk
hypothetically right
um and and during this pledge week then
got arrested for drunken disorderly
Behavior as a result of my pledge
choices
um and then the next day was out with my
pledge people again and this time as
part of my pledge activities committed
shoplifting of something of value
so I've now got a second offense that
fits within this criteria
and then on the third day
um perhaps representative attendance are
it's gone back to being a police officer
state police officer and sees me you
know running through traffic on I-95 in
an inebriated State and takes me into
protective custody she's starting to
sound like a RICO case
I've I've now got three offenses within
one week
and would that then necessitate based on
the way this was written that I'd be
held in jail because I would obviously
not have been capable of adjudicating
any of them yet
so thank you for the question so I'll
make a couple assumptions one is at the
first two events resulted in class A
misdemeanors being charged the third
offense would at least
um initially uh I think the way I would
read this result in in a detention
hearing it does not require that
detention be the permanent solution for
that third offense it says simply that
there's a rebuttable presumption that
the person would not be able to abide so
in that third instance
um hypothetically you would be
explaining to the judge how uh how you
would rebut that presumption of uh of
not being released
thank you but
so if I as a Class A misdemeanor one of
these others would that then put me in
this situation
as I read the bill I would put you in
the position of having a rebuttable
presumption but there is a presumption
of pre-trial detention but you would be
able to rebut that
represent jambren thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um I understand bill has several stages
you could be billed prior to the trial
after the trial and the finding of guilt
you're also billed until you're
sentenced
and then after your sentence until you
surrender to the house of correction
you'd still be considered under unveil
is that correct I think that's right I'm
not this is not you're exceeding my
level of of knowledge I did not practice
criminal law so I always get a little
bit uncomfortable when I get into a too
much of a detail and follow up
uh the reason for my question is is
worded that while on release pending
resolution uh Would we not consider the
resolution to be the conviction
I think that is an interpretation of it
thank you
is AB Newell
uh representative pru has been waiting
go ahead
thank you
in your opinion listening to
representative Seeley
on a three-day spree perhaps she should
have been held
on the third judge before she went out
and crashed on the fourth day
I won't comment on her hypothetical oh
sorry to put you on this
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Mr Ed my uh I'm
curious you know yesterday of course we
had a wonderful little presentation
about
um the drug courts and also mental
health supports and I know that you know
when we're talking about these type of
cases a lot of the time you know as
we've established in this hearing
um you know it it very much overlaps
with substance use
issues and mental health issues right
um so I I was wondering if you could
just kind of uh clarify a little bit for
everyone maybe people who weren't there
yesterday with the state of mental
health support is because I think you
know we are seeing drug court expand but
I think you know we're we're still in
the process with mental health supports
am I right
um so thank you for the question yes I
mean
um so two parts one is is I do
appreciate everyone's uh attendance
yesterday at attending court and also
the the presentation I know some of you
were not able to make it if the
committee in the in the chairman
um would like uh judge Netto to present
to the full committee at any future
event by all means please feel free to
reach out
um and we can arrange that you know any
aspect of when we're dealing with Drug
Court mental health court and
criminal cases in general there is in
this large percentage of cases a mental
health aspect to to the case and
within the drug court system
it is uh
very actively tied towards treatment and
that necessarily involves mental health
and drug addiction issues based upon
just the the close tie between between
the two
um but that said in terms of a mental
health court we are at very early stages
of being able to develop protocols and
systems where there's a science-based uh
protocols that can be implemented to
have an effective mental health court
and that is something that we are
actively working on but is behind where
we are in terms of the drug court
implementation which has been a very
successful program doesn't mean everyone
graduates from it successfully but it
means that within the parameters of the
program we're having a great deal of
success and and even within that context
the use of punishment and reward is a
very delicate balance in terms of
ultimately achieving success for the for
the persons that are involved and the
degree and the nature of the punishment
can ultimately affect whether or not
there will be a successful outcome in
that drug court proceeding and it's in
there is a great deal of science-based
uh
processes that are being implemented in
that system that we're starting to work
on through mental health issues but but
a a much more complicated and
um
and and not as as common in terms of of
how courts are addressing it but we are
starting down that process in that road
but we're ways away from having a a
well-implemented mental health court
system
representative Sue Newman
yes thank you for taking this question
several times there have been comments
about data collection and how useful
that would be and I wrote down a data
collection Software System are you aware
of any states anywhere in the United
States that do have a good working
system
um so thank you for the question I've
not
um gone out personally to evaluate what
other states are doing in terms of
collecting bail data I suspect there are
systems that are that are available to
do it it's not that it is not possible
to do it is the level of resources we
would have to add into our current
system to be able to do it so it's not
only the technology but it's also the
human resources to be able to ensure
that we are keeping data because data
doesn't get generated automatically
somebody has to be putting it in and it
has to be data that's useful and that
ultimately can be available to to those
who need it and that requires a human
being to sit in in real time input data
into the system on the status of bail
and that that just requires in in
essentially every Court somebody
dedicated to being able to do that
I mean we currently don't have that that
level of resource or the technology to
implement that and then it also has to
communicate with in real time to an
officer who's on you know in the street
and we do have some information that
does do that and and the question is
trying to add an additional sort of
level of information and data that's not
currently in the system into that system
and and it it just requires time
technology in human beings
and money and money yeah and that's
online
um so you know further questions thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you is there anyone else wishing to
testifying this bill was not testified
on this bill
see Nana hereby close the public hearing
and
um
if anyone's here for the executive
sessions I just want to give you a heads
up we're probably not going to do those
I'm going to end up opening and
recessing them to next Wednesday so put
it on your calendars if you're here to
testify in the next bill
um I know you've been here a while but
we are going to take a 10-minute bio
break and we'll be right back
thank you
this point we're going to open the
public hearing
on
what's the next one calling on sp252
and the chair recognizes Senator Susie
to introduce her bill
thank you so much Mr chairman for the
record I'm Senator Donna soucy I
represent Senate District 18 comprised
of the town of Litchfield and five Wards
in the city of Manchester
and I'd like to start my testimony this
morning by first thanking you and each
one of the members of the committee I
know the previous hearing was a long one
I know the issues are difficult but I
truly appreciated being here to hear the
very thoughtful questions and discussion
around this super important issue
um there are some things that I
certainly took away from the discussion
and from the questions that were asked
uh I have stack of file folders in front
of me they actually all relate to the
issue of bail reform and I say that
because
I have been involved though not directly
in the initial legislation or the study
committee but have been involved in the
issue for a while
and I think
what much of the testimony you heard on
the previous bill should show is that
contextually speaking
they'll reform
the first piece of legislation was
introduced with
a primary goal of ensuring that an
individual doesn't sit in a jail simply
because they don't have a dollar in
their pocket
and I think that still is one of the
most important goals that finances alone
should not be the reason that someone is
stuck in jail but I do think that
certainly many of those who spoke before
me
sort of outlined what the system is that
this new bell reform legislation knew
five years ago was placed upon and that
is a system that unfortunately is very
inconsistent
that doesn't fully collect all of the
data
and I you know I had forgotten that the
the good representative representative
scitec has been a bail commissioner but
I I do think that we
created
a system for the right reasons for good
reasons
but that we didn't have the
infrastructure to support it and by that
I'm not criticizing any of the
individuals that serve as bail
Commissioners or the court system
but
there are a myriad of differences
between what happens when someone is
provided personal recognizance bail in
Hillsborough County versus in koas
County
or Sullivan County we know that the bail
Commissioners are not mandated to have
training we know that many times the
bail Commissioners go without any
compensation
um we have a number of things that I
think are very important that we need to
reflect upon I think there's some great
work being done so you know heard
earlier with the study committee that
representative Harriet gathwaite uh
introduced I think representative Roy's
initiative to ensure that there are more
resources are all very important
but none of these things are going to
happen at once
these things have been systemic for a
while
and I think if we sort of step back and
look at that there are some discreet
things that we can do to ensure that
we're doing our job as legislators
a couple things I do want to comment on
uh that were also said earlier Professor
Sher was one of my law professors
he's not just a law professor he's a
great law professor and there are
several things he said that I actually
agree with
um
but I do have to say even he
acknowledged the system in New Hampshire
is not well defined it's more of a back
end system than a forward end system
when it comes to the engagement and
making these decisions about whether or
not somebody should be out on bail
um
he also talked about the data and I know
many of you had questions about the data
um
is his data is limited in scope the
scope of data that's available but it's
not a complete set of data upon which we
can make decisions and I think that's
something that we can all agree on as
well so this bill a little different
than the previous bill this bill
attempts to upon arrest
identify certain crimes for which
someone should be held pending
appearance before a judge
so instead of going before a bail
commissioner or and you can see on page
one beginning on line 24 for the crimes
that we've delineated
the individual would be held pending the
appearance before a judge now you may
hear that this is going to leave someone
incarcerated for days and days well I
would argue that there I can't argue
that there won't be one or two or a
couple of instances where
because a crime is committed on a Friday
night
and because weekend days are excluded
because the court isn't open someone may
have to wait
but what I will tell you is that given
the volume
of some of these potential cases given
the potential for a magistrate system
given other things that this good
committee is working on
um I think this makes sense for the
times that we're in I know you're being
given a lot of different options as to
how we might rework the statute
but I think that also speaks to the fact
that maybe we do need to look back at
what we did five years ago and fine tune
it not throw it out but fine tune it and
I think this bill is a very discreet way
that we can do that
I also want to speak to you uh about the
issue of or the term anecdotes because
you are going to hear semantes you are
going to hear some stories of where
someone
fell victim to a crime then someone was
apprehended for that crime and some very
dire things occurred as a result of it
um
I think there are people
on on both sides I think there are
victims I also think that we have to be
Mindful and respectful in creating a
process that recognizes that someone
who's been arrested
is innocent until proven guilty that is
our system
but we also have to keep Public Safety
in the Forefront of this discussion as
well you know in the Senate chamber that
room was used for the Supreme Court at
one time
and as a result if you look between the
windows on the top there are scales of
Justice
and those skills
are about balance are about weighting
the factors and how we as legislators
are going to craft laws that weigh those
important factors of Justice
and I just want to say that I think the
current process
has left some people
um
out in the cold so to speak particularly
with respect to victims I've spent
a lot of my time as a legislator working
on issues particularly surrounding
domestic violence I sponsor the domestic
violence law that created
it was called Joshua's Law that created
the crime of domestic violence and I
know for a fact although the chair
beside me is empty if I could have
actually brought someone with me whose
story I've heard I know that they would
have told you that there are crimes
today that are going unreported
because of fear that somebody
the alleged perpetrator could be
released
in a situation of domestic violence in
particular that's critical if somebody
is afraid that if they report a crime if
the person living in their home remember
somebody who shares a relationship
likely living in their home is going to
be released immediately
they fail to report that crime I think
that's
that sort of weighing the scales in a
way that that really does give me pause
and that really does concern me I think
on a lot in a lot of our
cities and towns and as I said you'll
hear some anecdotal information but
remember each anecdote includes a victim
and every alleged crime whether a person
is convicted or not still
uh includes a victim of that crime
um I think the word has gotten out that
our system is just tilted a little more
in the wrong direction for some of the
people in our state
and although I received great training
as a lawyer and I do practice labor and
employment law I'm here before you as a
state senator who's heard many real
stories from my constituents about the
impact of the law we passed five years
ago and about the need to make some very
discrete changes to it to ensure that we
are treating victims and perpetrators
fairly and that we are ensuring the
safety of the public of the State of New
Hampshire so with that I will conclude
my testimony I'm happy to take any
questions as I say I know that the chief
from Manchester is here can certainly
speak to some specific incidents about
this
this particular Bill the impact uh that
the initial bail reform has had and how
this bill might help with that problem
so thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
say no questions thank you for your
testimony I'm sorry representative I
just like that I just wanted to see if
anybody else had a question uh Mr chair
I have a brief comment and a question
for Senator Susie since my only chance
to see you uh we I pay attention bell
commissioner yes in Rockingham County I
want you to know based on what you
started your testimony with that the
veil reform originated with not keeping
people in jail only because of poverty
uh we just don't do that and I talk to
the people in Rockingham County we don't
do that and nobody's ever mentioned
Rockingham counties always Cheshire or
Sullivan but never rocking him we don't
do that that's my comment which is thank
you for listening my question is how did
you come up with this list
um this list actually was worked on
um over a couple of years
um this list appeared in legislation
that
um passed the Senate before I should
note this bill passed the Senate on a
21-3 vote but the list was a bipartisan
collaboration Senator Bradley had
similar legislation previously I picked
up on this legislation and we were
attempting to determine some of the most
serious offenses for which there should
at least be a pause and careful
consideration about someone being
released on bail
thank you
thank you Senator thank you very much
the chair recognizes Senator Abbas
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Senator Daryl
Abbas I represent District 22.
it's communities of Pelham Salem
Atkinson and
plasto
that's a joke between me and one of the
representatives
I'm testifying in support of Senate Bill
and I just want to point out we had a
hearing on 249 and they're very
different policies and if you look at
the vote in the Senate they were
different numbers so they're independent
of each other and I just asked to give
each one Fair consideration because this
policy I feel deals more with a specific
narrow issue there's a list of offenses
and those 12 offenses what they all have
in common
there's two there's two major things one
they're a violent crime where the victim
is a person so we're not talking about
property damage even breaking entering
we're talking about a crime with the
victim is a person and it's a violent
offense we have domestic violence
stalking those type of those type of
charges or it involves a sex crime
involving a child
that's the other type of offenses
for those 12 offenses if someone is
charged with any of those
the only change in policy is they'll
still have a hearing where they can be
held
they can assess the dangerousness of
that person
but they're going before a judge they
will not be released through a bail
commissioner that is not we're not
targeting bail Commissioners we're not
saying that the law is not being applied
correctly
but we're looking at some of the more
egregious unintended consequences of
bail reform and trying to address those
without repealing the whole thing or
reverting back to the prior system
so this language may seem similar to the
members that are on the committee last
term we've we've had a this policy
before us one difference is that we
separated the bill into several
several bills and the reason for doing
that is that's if you perhaps if you're
not in support of one policy you can
still support the other rather than have
one big Bill and that was the strategy
that I thought maybe better suited to
perhaps address some of the problems
there is a glaring hole in the procedure
and in the law because yes the state
does have the opportunity to challenge
that person's release if they are
released by a bail commissioner and can
request a hearing
if if the state believes the person is
dangerous however if that person has
already been released by a bail
commissioner
in in theory the court could still hold
the person after the dangerousness
hearing but that dangerous person has
been released into the public for uh 48
hours so that's the hole in the
procedure if the state wants to ask for
that hearing
it seems that it should be asked before
the person is released and they don't
even have the opportunity to do that
because the person that practices a
person will waive their arraignment if
they're given if they're awarded bail by
the bail commissioner
so
I think we're dealing with specific
public safety concerns and and just an
example of some of the
when I see egregious unintended
consequences there was a person who was
arrested for domestic violence
they were released within a short time
within two hours that same night
went to that person's house
broke into their house and then
committed a felony level sexual assault
on that person
same victim within 24 hours
it's in domestic violence is type
offense that tends to elevate and that's
there's plenty of Statistics showing
that it may start as a misdemeanor
offense and elevates and that's a one of
the most obvious examples of seeing that
but
that person was given bail without even
appearing before a judge all were saying
is this person will be brought before a
judge I understand that there's an
initiative to perhaps convert to a
magistrate system
I believe this is a safeguard to take
into consideration until that system is
put into place because as you can see
the Baylor procedure is very complicated
it's a long chapter and there's a lot of
procedural steps that can be taken
whether it's a magistrate or remain in
the current system we have now
but in the meantime we have glaring
public safety concerns that need to be
addressed this a deal this deals with
that in the short term while we perhaps
work together to put together a
magistrate system
uh I can't stress this enough
Public Safety when you're talking about
violent crimes with the victims of
people and crimes of violent crimes or
sex crimes against children those are
those are as egregious and as bad as
worse of an offense as a person can
commit these are the most dangerous of
the most dangerous and I feel that if
that person is going to be granted bail
or be released it should go before a
judge and the state should have the
opportunity to seek the remedy or seek
the bail that they see fit but keep in
mind
the state does not is not required to
actually ask that the person be held
they can waive that they so it's not
mandating that anyone be held on bail
the state would still have to meet their
burden of proof there's two different
processes we may come across if a person
is in is indicted for an offense
uh the comment the common practice of
that it could be the result of a longer
investigation that went into that
and I can imagine that the prosecutor
will be in a better position to meet
their burden but someone who's arrested
on a Thursday and then there first thing
in the morning that prosecutor better
have their information together they're
gonna have a tough time meeting that
burden that's that would fall on on the
prosecutor for not being prepared for
the hearing but at least they have the
option
the discretion to ask for it rather than
the person be released and we take our
chances and see what happens I think
given the level of offense is this is
not an egregious policy I hope the
committee would support not to pass I'll
be glad to answer any questions
Representative no
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Senator Abbas so in
the last bit in the last hearing what we
had heard from Professor share was that
that one would be unconstitutional and
what I wrote down and I may be lacking a
little bit I didn't get the support the
the case written down just in time but
it it there must be a hearing
representation must be provided and the
burden is on the state to demonstrate
that the person is a danger to the
public and so when I'm reading this the
court shall order that the person be
detained pending trial of course it
talks about how there will be a hearing
pending trial if the court determines by
clear and convincing evidence which I'm
pretty sure that's what he was saying
needed to be demonstrated that would be
putting the burden on the court that the
person release of a person is the danger
to the public or themselves so I just
wanted to clarify essentially what this
does is this removes
um what was what was a barrier in the
last one this one satisfies those
constitutional necessities
in respect of the Constitutional
question and let's leave it that this is
my opinion alone
so in that in 249 the when we had that
policy last term there was discussion
and in consultation with
the Attorney General's office other
people in the legal community
was if that said clear and convincing
evidence all you're trying to in that
scenario all you're doing is trying to
demonstrate that state is demonstrating
you've been arrested so whether that
says probable cause clear and convincing
evidence or Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
the bottom line is to demonstrate the
person's been arrested two times
thereafter after the first offense being
released on bail
we're not talking about anything more
than their criminal record or perhaps
the arrest report
so the reason why it says probable cause
is that that's the arrest standard if we
change that to clear and convincing
evidence the court would be required to
make two separate written findings and
that would one be I don't believe is a
good use of resources
because regardless of the burden it's
you're demonstrating have they been
arrested for more than one offense and
if you ask the person if the person
wishes to testify
they can they may state that they may
state that for the sake of yes I've been
arrested here's my charges they're open
charges it's public record
with that with that being said the clear
and convincing evidence standard
my understanding is that that Salerno
case the holding was limited to the
interpretation of the current of the
bail chapter that it was before the
court and it's not necessarily bonding
on that policy so this says clear and
convincing evidence but here you can
only have one offense and you're going
to be held pending trial because the
assessment is whether you pose a danger
to the public safe to the public or to
yourself and can also take I think
Salerno also talked about being a Flight
Risk where 249 the analysis is well you
keep getting violating your conditions
of your release now it's a that's a
different analysis because we're saying
we've given you bail and you didn't
abide by the conditions on more than one
occasion here you can have no prior
criminal record you can have nothing
pending for any court and now you've
been arrested and the consideration is
what should you be held without bail but
whether you're held under 249 or you're
held under 252 is still the speedy trial
law that it's a constitutional right but
it is defined in an RSA if you are being
held I believe the case and I was
actually in between my testimony I was
actually that's what I was doing over
there reading about that is
if you're being held they will the court
will expedite your case and give it
priority over someone who's not being
held because of that constitutional
issue because the speedy trial analysis
is well by not getting your speedy trial
have you suffered any Prejudice well if
you're being held
or awaiting your trial I could say that
that's pretty clear what that's a
Prejudice if you're not being held it's
much harder to demonstrate that you
suffer to prejudice
I think
and I you know I just want to clarify it
so correct me if I'm wrong the the
difference is in the uh you know the
difference is what is the standard what
is the Constitutional standard for when
someone should be deprived of their
Liberty when someone should be detained
um and and not able to to move around
freely or whatever so I mean that seems
to be the difference for me so if it's
an arrest which is simply an arrest and
that person could be released uh after
that that's one burden right and then
what we're talking about here is the
burden for whether they should be
um detained until they have until trial
right
yes but the one of them is is the burden
is clear and convincing evidence but the
states arguing are trying to demonstrate
you pose a public safety threat to
yourself
poor to the public or in solerno it
talks about it being a Flight Risk
when it comes to the conditions of your
release that is completely different
because you may not pose a danger to the
public at all but you're not abiding by
the conditions conditions of your
release can be several things one can be
that you submit to random drug and
alcohol screens uh one can be that you
remain sober
those that can one can be that you
submit to a mental health evaluation and
especially if these are agreed upon and
if a person doesn't abide by those
well again what is the consequence of
not abiding by your conditions but
that's a different analysis because
you're not necessarily considering
whether they're a threat to the public
or whether they um
or a Flight Risk it's the violations of
the conditions
thank you
scitec
Senator Abbas I have a couple questions
concerning if I may concerning this list
as I heard
it being described it was the abuse of a
child or the actual physical molestation
do you see that the safety of the public
is involved is it threatened under
possession manufactured Distributing of
child sexual abuse images blah blah
however repulsive that may be I don't
see where how do you see tell me how
Public Safety is affected by that
immediately
first of all I would give I would I if
you want to sponsor an amendment to
remove the child pornography provision
I'll let this committee evaluate that
but I would the Supreme Court
and they've ruled on this and this is
the Supreme Court United States that
when you're in possession of child
pornography the mere fact that you
support the market the industry that in
and of itself is harmed to a child so
you may say oh I'm not harming the child
because I you know I'm only watching the
video well you're supporting the market
where that child was harmed in that
video never goes away so that child's
still a victim whether you're the the
physical actor or you're you're
supporting it that's what the Supreme
Court says so I stand by that
well you've answered my question uh the
second one is this in the Bare Bones
anecdote that you talked about
would the judge with respect to woman
feloniously sold all that would a judge
have done anything different giving your
bare bones recital then issue a no
contact
assuming that the domestic violence
arrest was the first offense again you
have to take in account the individual
factors does that person have a criminal
record have they been convicted of other
prior domestic violence offenses do they
have a restraining active restraining
order there's a lot of other factors
that can be taken into consideration
when assessing whether someone is a
danger to themselves of Public Safety in
this case
that would not have happened simply
because the person would have been held
and brought before a judge
they never went before a judge they were
released by a bail commissioner now
would a judge made the same conclusion I
cannot answer that I'm not I'm not clear
if the um
if the prosecutor would have even asked
asked for that person be held but what I
will point out is
in this scenario
was the evaluation even made by the
court to even consider it was never went
before court and
consider it a cool and off period
someone committed a violent offense
do we want to release that person right
away do we want that person brought
before a judge
it could be again if it's a repeat
offender I think it's worth having that
hearing and let let the
County attorney decide what to do if
they want to go forward with it and let
the court make their determination
I have one question
yeah I uh good to see you before us
today I just had one question about the
hours 24 hours and 36 hours is that
enough time to get together
a judge to bring people before a judge
thank you for the question that time
period is consistent with the circuit
court and Superior Court rules it was
taking right from there so anyone who
has an issue with those rules I mean
that's I don't want to take credit for
you know supporting that that language
already there so I think it's important
with any policy have consistent language
in this this stays with that
thank you testimony
chair recognizes Allen
Chief Ellenberg sorry
how about now well there I am all right
so I
like the chairman said I'm Alan
waldenberry I'm the chief of police uh
for the Manchester police department and
have been sold for approximately two and
a half years
I sit here today in support of Senate
bill 252. you know again I will be brief
overall crime may be down but crime
types that are significantly more
harmful the community are up
the types of refunding right the types
of reoffending while on bail are
alarming
the inability to hold offenders some
offenders results in Greater harm to the
community through more victimization
there is now no determined effect to
arrest bail reform was passed without
adequate pre-trial services so there's
no oversight of offenders who do bail
others that you've heard from today will
state that crime is actually down since
bail reform began and therefore there is
no evidence that the changes to the law
of Maine New Hampshire are less safe
the fact is yes overall crime may be
down in New Hampshire however that is an
oversimplification of what our
communities are really experiencing and
many of you here today represent the
community that I serve in
this is because different crimes cause
different harms a proper assessment
includes detailed analysis of certain
types of crimes to understand true
changes in crime since bail reform began
since bail reform began in Manchester we
have seen simple assaults increase by
six percent theft from buildings
increase 145 percent
theft from Motor Vehicles increased by
16 percent thefts of motor vehicle parts
and accessories increased 38 percent
credit card credit fraud
increased by 15 percent
my highest priority is violent crime in
the reduction of it and a key indicate
key indicator we access is gun crime
since bail reform began gun crime in
Manchester is up 10 percent it was up 40
percent year to year for 2022.
gunfire incidents where an actual gun
was fired is up 18 18 since bail reform
began
fortunately our Relentless efforts on
this problem is seeing some success and
we've been able to reduce non-fatal
shootings by approximately 40 percent in
2022.
it is no coincidence that these
increases have occurred since bail
reform began the lack of ability to hold
prolific offenders pending trial
increases reoffending and absolutely
makes our communities less safe
the type of reoffending we are seeing in
Manchester is alarming
from April to December of 2022 again
just from April to December
we had over 700 arrests where the people
reported to us at a time of arrest that
they were out on bail again that's just
from April to December I'm not going
back from
did not have time to go back from
January to April so in that time period
over 700 arrests with the arrest he was
out on bail for a prior offense
nine were arrested for robbery
nine were arrested for burglary
32 were arrested for weapons offenses
while out on bail 18 were arrested for
aggravated assault while out on bail
and one was arrested for murder while on
bail
I could go on and on ladies and
gentlemen anecdotal but I'll give you
just one
um
had one individual in the city of
Manchester arrested for two counts of
simple assault released on an unsecured
Bond arrested again seven days later for
another count of simple assault stalking
and violation of failed conditions
domestic related
arrested again on 9 13.
of 22 for a kind of resisting arrest
released on PR bail arrested again on 9
16 for one count of falsifying physical
evidence at class B felony one
possession one kind of possession of
controlled drug a B felony
and again violation of bail conditions
he was held for four days
bear was then set at 500 PR
arrested again on 9 28 for one count of
stocking in violation to bail again
released on a thousand dollars PR
arrested again on 10-6 for one count of
armed robbery
one kind of fell into possession of a
dangerous weapon class B felony
one kind of receiving stolen property at
B felony fraudulent use of a credit card
in one count of one count of falsifying
physical evidence another felony
billed by the court
unknown what the bill was because we're
not able to find it in their system to
the gentleman's point and I'm sorry I
apologize I forget your name but the
he's absolutely right in regards to our
ability to track bail accurately is a
real problem and the gentleman is uh
absolutely right in his comment on that
arrested again
um on 12 26 again another B felony
released
finally arrested on
January 30th of this year after being
after several cases were issued out of
Hillsboro Superior Court after being
involved in a pretty significant pursuit
in a fight with my police officers in
which uh at least one or two were in uh
injured as a result of
um dealing with this individual
so for those that
you know I think people
and I don't think you people here do
this but
people tend to minimize the
victimization when it's not really in
their living room or it's not in your
front yard
um and once it becomes reality for
people those are the people that I get
phone calls from when they're a
first-time victim and they say hey chief
what's wrong with the system why wasn't
this person not held and it's hard for
it's not hard it's my job to explain to
my constituents many of which are yours
and explain the difficulties of the bail
and the bail system
and to have those difficult
conversations with these victims and to
get them to understand the process is
sometimes difficult and it's not their
fault
um so again I urge you to support this
bill I think it's a good start I think
it's a compromise am I in support of the
previous Bill yes I am because the
quality of life is impacting your
constituents that represent the city of
Manchester and if you think it's not I
encourage you to reach out to me come in
and do a ride along and I'll take you
around the city and I will show you
where your repeat prolific offenders are
impacting the city of Manchester in the
quality of life because our people in
this state in particular in Manchester
in particular as a state as a whole
deserve better from this body and law
enforcement just wants to be part of
that solution so thank you for your time
we'll take questions
representative scitec please pardon a
little defensiveness on my part but I
try to do a pretty good job and I've
listened to your list of incidents there
were at least two where the violence the
rusty was violating stalking
that's a problem with the court that a
judge had to let him out no nobody can
release a stalking repeat stalker
accepted court is that not true that's
true sir I wasn't attacked I was I'm not
attacking bail commissioner sir I've
worked with them for the last 27 years
um it's a very difficult job it's a
thankless job
um I think sometimes they
I know they do the best they can every
day when they come in and they're often
oftentimes presented
um you know with minimal information
have to make very difficult decisions is
there a problem you know quite frankly
you know
I think from County to County court to
court where a person appears the
circumstances are going to be different
I don't think to your point I think
there's a lack of consistency across the
courts in regards to who's released and
who's not released
um are you and I going to fix that
no
maybe for a judge someday but probably
not going to happen
representative Cameron
thank you Mr chairman thank you chief
for taking my question
it sounds like in that particular case
something failed now was it the law was
it the justice that that uh set bail in
your in your opinion I I value your
opinion you've got a lot of experience
who do you think uh could have prevented
that from going any further
overall
um to be honest with you probably
probably a judge
um in recognizing the escalation of
behavior
obviously I laid it out over a short
period of time
very violent individual that was you
know had potential to kill somebody
um
I would say that you know a judge should
have recognized that now you know to
Professor Shearer's Point
um yeah there are times when you know
prosecutors don't make the appropriate
argument they don't read they don't
raise reach the bar that could be for a
lot of reasons or they don't make the
argument so it's really it's a
combination of you know the total system
um
hopefully that answers your question sir
you know further questions thank you
Chief thank you for your time ladies and
gentlemen
chair recognizes Frank knack
uh Mr chair members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank Knack policy
director with the ACLU of New Hampshire
here in opposition to HB or SB 252
um
uh so the handout has a lot of the
information I'll be referring to
including in the um the the appendix to
the handouts
um but really just want to focus on the
the basic fact that we've all talked
about before that again the current bail
statute provides Myriad opportunities to
hold any individual if they violate
their conditions if a prosecutor
disagrees with their lease order
Etc there are multiple ways that someone
can be held and the beauty of the
current statute is that it's
individualized it takes the individual
who comes before the bail commissioner
before the judge that person can look at
that person's facts in that case and
determine if that person is a danger or
Flight Risk as the Constitution requires
it is a system that has functioned well
and when we have heard concerns with the
existing system these anecdotes when you
actually dig into the anecdotes as
representative sitak pointed out the
facts don't match the anecdote so in the
case of stalking where it wasn't a bail
commissioner it was a judge who made the
order again under this I'm under this
proposed Bill the individuals are not
going to be held pre-trial indefinitely
they're going to be held for a couple of
days and taken away from their lives
until they get before a judge they're
just going to miss the bail commissioner
um and so in that case again that person
could be released so in the case of
Representative sideak uh mentioned we
also heard earlier in the Senate
testimony on this bill when this bill
was originally introduced the big
anecdotal case that they were relying
upon was the horrific murder in
Manchester which happened last year and
so when that murder happened again it
was a frontal attack on bail system has
failed and it wasn't until when
Professor Sher who who had to
unfortunately leave and you can't
testify in this bill but I think he'll
be sending you notes when he actually
dug into that case and looked at the
facts in that case where it became clear
that it had nothing to do with bail
Commissioners it had to do it had
nothing to do with the courts it had to
do with prosecutors not doing their job
in multiple instances and to lead to
that person to not be held so again
using that that anecdote was the
anecdote that we were going to repeal
Bill reform with until the facts came
out again we heard another anecdote here
but when we actually look at the facts
behind these anecdotes it's all too
often that the facts don't match the
rhetoric and so we're deeply concerned
that we would be repealing an entire
section of a bail reform based on these
anecdotes that are that are kind of
paper thin when you start digging
um we also heard the chief talk about I
think probably assuming what what we had
testified in the past that we were going
to talk about reductions in crime rates
in New Hampshire well that isn't a you
know an undeniable fact since bail
reform in New Hampshire crime we're
talking about group a crime and so just
so you know our source for this it's the
department of safety has great crime
records data so we took Department of
State these information from 2018 which
is your bail reform through 2021 which
was the most recent year for uh data
available crime overall on group a
crimes which is all violent offenses and
the majority of other offenses is down
in Bedford where we heard the chief
testify on the last bill group a crimes
and arrests are down 21 over 21 percent
in Manchester group a crimes and arrests
are Down group a crimes are down 13
arrests are down 33 percent and so while
they're absolutely going to be
cherry-picked opportunities to say well
in this case crime has gone up it's gone
down drastically over the past four or
five years since bail reform uh in New
Hampshire in Bedford and Manchester
um and so I'm not going to sit here and
say bail reform is the reason that crime
has decreased that would be disingenuous
of me but the the fact that others are
trying to argue that bill reform has
somehow undermined Community safety is
again not backed by any actual facts
um again we also heard Public Safety and
I talked a little bit about this in on
the last bill but the fact of the matter
is when you actually look if we really
care about public safety and we actually
look at the impact of carceral
approaches pre-trial the data is
absolutely crystal clear Decades of data
on this issue that holding people
pre-trial unless there's individualized
determination of dangerness is actually
a net harm to the communities because
it's going to pull them out of their
Community it's going to increase their
likelihood of recidivating down the road
because they have been pulled away from
the community from their job access to
employment Etc
um
and finally
um you know that we have great
opportunities to actually look forward
and to strengthen the bail system so uh
representative Harry gathwright's Bill
to move towards uh potentially studying
whether it would make sense to have a
magistrate system or some hybrid
magistrate bail commissioner system
whatever that might look like and
actually taking time to look through
that uh chairman Roy's work to get the
funding into the budget around real-time
bail tracking system those are concrete
steps that we can take to ensure that we
have a bail system that is stronger
versus this which is an anecdote-based
attempt to which will result only in
individuals being held unnecessarily
potentially thousands of individuals
every year and so from Australia's
perspective the cost savings argument is
less important to us but also you know
we're talking about 1.5 I think million
dollars just on the state level for the
courts that does nothing to talk about
the fact that we're going to be spending
105 to 125 a day to jail and all those
individuals which would be an unfunded
mandate on all of your localities
particularly I think it's important from
a cost savings from an ace perspective
from a cost perspective because we do
know things that will actually improve
if we really care about Public Safety
housing access is connected to Public
Safety there's reductions in crime when
you have better access to housing there
are multiple ways that if we really are
concerned about Public Safety that we
can investing those dollars to actually
make our community safer so happy to
take any questions and really appreciate
the opportunity to testify thank you
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Knack we heard a
lot of different statistics today I'm
just wondering if you could address what
Chief eldenburg said about crime is down
but the specific crimes that are hurting
people whether it's property crimes for
the catalytic converters or whatever
um else the chief had said he said those
were up despite crime being down I
wonder if you could address that point
yeah definitely so these this is what
the sheet looks like if you go to the
Department of safety's website so this
is Manchester for example so all the
group a offenses by offense type and
then reported and cleared arrests and
um for adults and juveniles and so you
can definitely go through here and
cherry pick a few where crime may have
gone up slightly
um but overall and particularly for the
more serious offenses crime is down
substantially in Manchester in Bedford
in New Hampshire overall
um and so I'll go back and look at what
the specific I know I think you
mentioned like three or four crime types
so I can go back and look through that
um but I could also you know quickly
cherry pick a number of other specific
offenses where it's gone down
substantially I think it's important to
look overall at the data and then to
look at Trends thank you
representative Muse
thanks for taking my question
earlier we heard Senator Susie talk
about how a large part of why we're in
the situation we're in is really a
failure an infrastructure to support
um support the current law
um
I guess my question is
this particular bill doesn't attempt to
address those infrastructure issues at
all what it attempts to do is to change
the law
um
from a from a constitutional perspective
and I know one of the things we're
always very concerned we're always
concerned about the rights of victims
but I think we're also very much aware
of the power of the state over an
individual who might find himself or
herself in one of these situations from
a constitutional
perspective
um
does a bill like this pass pass muster
is are we still being as protective when
it comes to the rights of individuals as
we need to be if we if we pass a law
like this without actually addressing
any of the same the infrastructure
issues I guess I'm concerned that
the kind of infrastructure issues that
are making the current statute
occasionally fail
if we're not addressing them as as part
of this are we really are we really
helping or are we just sort of opening
up a constitutional bag of worms
no I definitely appreciate that question
and and to give a little bit of context
to my answer
um you know I think it is somewhat
frustrating
um the Monopoly that I think certain
folks think they have over certain terms
like victims and so from my perspective
you know before in this role I was
working I worked for the Montana
Innocence Project and so worked directly
every day with people including folks
two folks who had been held incarcerated
for 23 years each for a crime that they
didn't commit and that the police knew
they didn't commit on the front end and
so it is you know dealt with both both
of them and the trauma they faced their
family members on a daily basis talking
to them regularly about the trauma that
they faced not only you know being
separated from their family but also
having a loved one who was accused of a
heinous offense that everyone should
have known on the front end didn't
happen and so again when we heard from
Professor sure 36 percent of these cases
are dismissed or no pros and I think you
know there may be a few where the plea
impacted that but again we're assuming
that all these people committed the
fence when the facts are possibly very
likely that not a good chunk of those
folks didn't do anything in the first
place
um or were over drastically overcharged
but getting to the Constitutional clash
in the U.S you know the Supreme Court
has always been clear that individuals
there has to be an individualized
determination there has to be a finding
of dangerousness and it has to be a
finding at a clear and convincing level
and so again we have concerns with
blanket opportunity blanket holds like
this would have so you know there's
definitely some question here about how
this would because this is holding just
before a judge not all the way through
pre-trial detention so being transparent
I think there are some factors here that
might weigh there but I do think that
there are serious concerns here from a
constitutional perspective
um and again that I think our concern
with this as well the bigger picture
concern is we are just wholeheartedly
considering you're this person charged
with this offense is going to be held
regardless of the facts in that case
regard regardless of whether you know as
you all often know when prosecutors get
the case File they could be like oh this
is way overcharged I'm going to reduce
so that ignores all of those facts
um that we're just going to blanket hold
this whole set of people and do so at a
time when we have absolutely no hard
data to show that there's actually any
problem and that this is actually a
solution and when we do know the facts
are clear that there are Myriad ways
that individuals could be held right now
and that the for whatever reason would
be it prosecutors not doing their job
whatever they're not being held so we
have you know all these concerns
Mr connect can I ask you to stay uh I
can't believe the police held somebody
years that knew he didn't care but
that's not a question that's
think of your testimony
chair recognizes David Rothstein
uh good afternoon my name is David
Rothstein again I'm here uh on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense attorneys I am not
going to repeat uh comments I basically
just wanted to
State my I think what I have said before
is that the the best approach on bail
continues to be a totality of the
circumstances approach which would
consider certainly the nature of the
offense absolutely as a bail
commissioner as a judge when you hear
there's a certain offense you you raise
an eyebrow you focus in if it's
aggravated for any sexual assault or if
it's disorderly conduct on the street
corner you you have a much different
perspective you have to look at the
offense you have to look at
individualized factors as I believe
Senator Abba said you have to look at
the offender a couple of comments on
this list which other people have
commented on it starts with homicide and
it includes which is obviously the most
serious offense under our criminal code
it also includes
misdemeanor domestic violence or
stalking offenses it also includes
second-degree assault offenses which I
had done some prior research when I was
with the public defender there are many
second-degree assault offenses that are
overcharged and when you look at how
they ultimately resolve they resolve as
misdemeanors with no time once everybody
has a chance to look at them or even
lesser so to treat a homicide offense in
the same sort of sequence of crimes as
some of these other offenses seems to me
to be
improper if you think about homicide the
average sentence that a person is going
to get in a homicide case in New
Hampshire is about 30 to life the
average sentence that someone is going
to get on a first-time domestic violence
offense if the case goes to prosecution
is going to be a suspended sentence with
the opportunity to potentially
participate in some counseling the case
analysis in a homicide is also very very
different a homicide is being brought by
the Attorney General's office the cases
are typically extremely strong they
typically either go to trial where the
person is found guilty after trial of
first or second degree murder or where
there's a plea to something like 30
degrees to life these other types of
cases the the domestic violence case is
the second degree assault cases the case
analysis is very very different we talk
about this as being a back-end system if
you look at the back end those cases do
not tend to get significant jail
sentences or prison sentences they
oftentimes don't even result in felony
convictions
I think that there are some people
charged with aggravated feloniosexual
assault who absolutely should be
detained pending trial I've had some of
those clients I had a Manchester client
who was alleged to be a serial rapist in
Manchester he was detained pending trial
we had a trial he was convicted I've had
other clients charged with aggravated
formosexual assault where perhaps its
delayed report for many years ago the
client has no criminal record the client
has no reason to have any contact with
the alleged victim and that person is
released on bail in the case the case
goes forward that way so again I do
think you have to look at individual
circumstances armed robbery is on this
list I don't think there are too many
bail Commissioners who are going to look
at somebody charged with armed robbery
with a weapon and who are going to just
say hey you know PR bail we'll see you
at court I think that type of offense
the the system is working that type of
person is not going to be given a PR
bail as a typical matter I don't think
the system is broken I think that even
24 to 36 hours in jail can be a very
very significant period of time for a
person a very significant interruption
in their life and as far as the
permanent attention goes and being
driven by the offense I do agree that
courts attempt to give priority to
incarcerated cases but if you check with
our Superior Courts they're scheduling
even incarcerated clients out several
months for trial at this point due to
the volume of cases that that exist so
in some I I don't I understand
the very eloquent comments that were
made in support of the statute but I
respectfully disagree that it's
necessary and I'll take any questions if
there are any
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman I I just want to make sure I
I'm understanding this so when Senator
Susie testified
she made it adamantly clear that
that this is affecting
the crimes where their victim was a
person yes right so you were just saying
was about
you know the disruption in someone's
life because they're they're not being
they're in prison I'm sorry that they're
being detained for possibly two to three
days right
but those are crimes
that there is a victim much I'm thinking
safe to assume that their lives are
probably disrupted for more than two to
three days so is there a difference from
what you're saying than what she was
saying I don't think so um I I think
that what I'm saying I'm obviously
talking about it from a different
perspective without question I'm talking
about it from the perspective of of the
offender I appreciate that these are
um what that what these crimes have in
common is that they all involve victims
they're not they're not property crimes
um what I'm saying is you you still have
to look at the nature of the offense and
the offender I mean a homicide is very
different from a domestic violence
simple assault or from a domestic
violence stalking offense they're just
very different offenses they're very
different offenders it may well be
appropriate to incarcerate somebody
on a first offense domestic violence or
to hold them for that 24 to 36 hour
period but not as a blanket matter I
think is all that I'm saying and I think
that in the case where a person should
be incarcerated in that period there are
going to be factors brought to bear
brought to the attention of the person
that the bail commissioner or the
magistrator whomever and that person can
make a decision on an individualized
basis rather than merely being driven by
the nature of the offense
to testimony
the court calls Attorney Richard head
excuse me the we're talking about court
so much the chair
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um somewhat different in this bill than
the last bill I do have some data I
wanted to share with you regarding the
impact of this bill and also a
Confluence of a couple of events that's
going to occur on January 1st in circuit
court so unrelated to this bill but
already passed in a previous session of
the legislature we have the repeal of
felonies first so under current practice
felonies are initiated in Superior Court
misdemeanors and violations are
initiated in Circuit Court
come January 1st in that in that process
is called felonies first felonies first
start in Superior Court and that was
implemented in around 2015. in the last
session felonies first was repealed so
we go back to an older system in which
all cases felonies misdemeanors
violations will initiate in circuit
court so none of those cases virtually
none of those cases will initiate in
Superior Court so come January 1st our
circuit court is going to have an influx
of
felonies that are not currently being
absorbed into the system and we have to
absorb those into the system and so what
that means in terms of of what is
circuit court so circuit court is made
up of three divisions uh District
division where the criminal cases are
heard Family Division where you have the
family type of of cases and probate
division where the where the probate
cases are heard all of those are heard
in Circuit Court same judges are hearing
the same cases in all those divisions we
don't we don't separate them out
probate's a little bit different
So within within Circuit Court we have
42 judges and
um on top of that we have some part-time
judges who are essentially retired
and they hear and they receive on an
annual basis under the current system
about a hundred and twenty seven
thousand new cases every year so we have
42 plus judges going through that we
have court staff processing all of those
cases it is a tremendous burden that
occurs within the circuit court system
come January 1st felonies first will be
repealed and we're going to add into
that system somewhere around eight to
nine thousand new criminal cases that
are not currently being absorbed into
the circuit court system because they're
starting currently in in Superior Court
and we're moving those into circuit
court so brand new cases not currently
in the dockets in the circuit court and
those will all now have to get opened by
Circuit Court staff they will all have
to get heard by Circuit Court judges and
those cases that are felonies if they
don't plea down to a misdemeanor in
circuit court at arraignment
or probably probable cause hearing will
then get transferred and restart over in
Superior Court and that's the the system
that you sort of approved last last
session
what this does so we so that's coming
January 1st and is is a process that is
taking up a fair amount of Court staff
time currently to try to figure out how
to how to do it and how to do it
smoothly
what this case what this bill adds to
that are cases that are not currently
being heard as detention hearings
detention bail hearings and adds the uh
into the load detention bail hearings
and we do have some data that suggests
about how many we're going to have post
felonies first repeal and and it's
somewhere in the neighborhood of
approximately 3 400 new detention bail
hearings that currently are are not
coming to the court as a detention bail
hearing essentially meaning that a bail
commissioner has likely issued a
personal recognizance bail
um and so the person's not being
detained and it's not coming to the
court as a detention hearing so those
then so for the folks who were at court
yesterday in the spirit Court those are
the ones that are likely to be heard on
that video arraignments that we saw that
the judge do at 10 o'clock and and those
are likely to be folks who are now in
the county jail
um who are going to be video arraigned
into the court on a daily basis so those
that that load just sort of has to get
added in so what does that mean and in
addition to having absorbed felonies
first into the system we now have to
absorb these bail hearings and these
bail hearings may not be one-offs
because if that bail hearing
um occurs in the first instance A
detention bail hearing and a public
defender has not been assigned for those
of you who saw yesterday the judge will
ask the individual do you want to argue
your bail today or do you want to wait
until the bail until a a
lawyers assigned to you and that might
be tomorrow because if you're in
detention
public defenders do quickly assign a a
lawyer to that case if you're not in
detention uh and you're charged with a
with a crime and you're eligible for for
a lawyer it can take
180 days sometimes for a lawyer to get
appointed and then the process can
essentially start if you're detained
it's going to happen quickly
um
so that might mean okay we've had the
the hearing today the individual has
decided I don't want to argue bail today
I want to wait to my lawyers assigned
the lawyer gets assigned lawyer files
bail paperwork we gotta have another
hearing within 24 hours of that of that
paperwork being filed so that's two
hearings now that may occur as a result
of that detention hearing and then if
the decision is uh one that results in
further detention by the judge that that
bail decision could be appealed so there
might be a third a hearing that comes
out of that but I'll focus on the one
so what we're talking about let's say
we're adding 3 400 new hearings
detention hearings into the system and
let's say each one of those hearings
takes six minutes that's probably low
but let's let's just say it takes six
minutes
if we do that
and add up add that over 3 400
new hearings that adds what are called
uh 46 session days to our schedule and
the session day is essentially
the seven and a half hours that a judge
has in a courtroom available to hear
cases so that's one session day we have
to add into the system 46 session days
just to handle that first round of
hearings from detention bail hearings so
what does that mean since since you're
not a finance group you're a policy
group what how does that impact you that
means within the system we have to
absorb 46 days of time of a judge not
doing something else so what is it the
judge has discretion to do or not do
that can add and absorb 46 days into the
system
so there are a number of things that by
Statute we have to do within a certain
period of time so landlord tenant has a
10-day deadline you got to have a
hearing
juvenile cases have statutory hearings
abuse and neglect cases have statutory
hearings and deadlines so there's a
number of things that have statutory
deadlines we've got to hear these cases
and we got to hear them within a certain
period of time
if we add up the total number of Judges
we have currently 42 plus the part-time
judges that are that are retired we have
a total number of session days available
to us so the number of seven and a half
hour days that these total that these
judges can sit in front of a uh in a
courtroom in total is about 16 000
session days so we can cover 16 000
session days with our judges to hear all
the cases
of those sixteen thousand about five
thousand five thousand of them are
locked into those things that have
statutory deadlines so we just have to
get those things done so that's about
five thousand that five thousand does
not include the criminal cases that's
about another three thousand uh session
days so net or thirty five hundred
actually
so now if we add all the things with
statutory deadlines in our criminal
cases
of the of the 16 000 session days
available we've consumed about 8 500 of
them
and so what that means is those things
that have discretionary deadlines we
don't have to do a statute that's not
Constitution that says we have to do it
those are getting pushed and the reality
is those are getting pushed so what type
of cases are we talking about civil
cases your small claims cases are
getting reached
much later than we would like them to
but that's because we're doing all these
other things so civil cases get pushed
uh divorce cases don't have deadlines
those get pushed and I spend a lot of
time in in the children and family law
committee and I hear a lot of complaints
about that our cases aren't getting
reached
um
uh some you know some there so there's
some Equity cases some trust cases you
know the things that don't have a
deadline just naturally because you're
pushing only so much into a system they
get pushed later and you hear about
those things so it's you know it becomes
a very intensive
resource issue and and in these numbers
I'm only talking about Judges so far
on top of that within our Clerk's
offices they
because of felonies first repeal have to
absorb another eight nine thousand cases
into what they do in the work that they
do and if I took just to open a case
let's say it's a half an hour to open a
case
for for
um for these types of cases that we're
talking about in this bill separating
out felonies first we have to absorb
about another 226 days worth of work by
by Court staff in order to process the
additional materials if you assume each
one and bail Commissioners know the
paperwork alone for these things takes a
while
in getting it processed so we have to
absorb that into the system and what we
also know is that based upon a study
that was conducted on our system last
year from the national Center of state
courts
that we currently are short if we don't
add felonies first into it if we don't
add bail reform into it in Circuit Court
we're short about 17 judges and we're
sure about 31 30 30 plus in terms of
staff
and we have in the in our budget this
year the chief justice has has asked for
significant resources and we ask for
support of that in the sense of of the
17 judges that are suggested he's asked
for seven of the Court staff he's asked
for 31 but he has not factored into you
know the additional workload that would
be added by new legislation
um so I I think in terms of of the
impacts and we don't have any view on
the policy we look at how does this
impact Court operations and the only
purpose of my testimony is to give you
that insight as you are deliberating on
the policy uh goals of this bill is that
they will have impacts within the court
system there's only so much that the
system can absorb and as we take on more
it just means stuff gets pushed you know
we hear complaints in a perfectly
legitimate issues that a Cornish issues
an order that doesn't get mailed out for
two or three weeks sometimes because
that Court staff is doing 20 other
things before they can get to the
mailing of that order and that's just a
reality of the work within the circuit
court so anytime we're adding loads into
the circuit court system we are we're
stressing what is a system that already
has a fairly high level of stress
um
but again I do want to emphasize we have
absolutely no position on the policy
goals of this if this is the the
direction that that the legislature
wants to take we have no view on that it
is simply
um the need then to accommodate the the
resources and also the understanding of
what that results in in terms of impact
on cases that are not criminal that are
not statutory deadlines and the effect
that it has but that I would conclude my
comments but I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you
thank you um if we were to take for
example the the magistrate system
contemplated in the study committee by
representative Eric Wright's bill with
that
um would that alleviate some of the
stress in in the system
um so thank you for the question yes
absolutely
um it would well we would see the the
responsibility of someone along the
lines of a magistrate would be to do a
lot within as employees of the system
trained within the system and hopefully
a smaller number so that we can get some
consistency within that group they would
handle a lot of the paperwork that would
be done by a clerk's office and would be
making the decision that a judge would
currently be making so it does offload
some of that the the stress is there it
doesn't eliminate all of the the sort of
work within the clerk's office so
there's still no matter what going to be
an increased burden within the clerk's
offices
um but that would alleviate sort of the
in court time that we're talking about
at least in the first hearing role
um as you know the the you get the
issues of of
um waiting for the appointment of of a
public defender or second or third
attempts at the at the bail decision
those would be less those would still
impact the courts in the same way but in
the first round that would definitely
have a positive impact in terms of
helping resource needs
so in in the opinion of the Court uh
via your opinion would um would passing
for example the current bill we're
discussing at the same time as we began
that that process of that study
commission for that would that be a wise
decision
um so thank you for the question I think
I think it'd be an excellent idea
um it you know one we don't want to be
implementing
um that process today because I think we
might have some some people break down
if we had it if we did that yeah
but it is a system I think has
substantial Merit and if we can identify
through a legislative process the best
way to implement that in conjunction
with bail commissioner roles and and
just how we would um how we would bring
that into fruition and also you know how
would we start to to accommodate
electronic bail which we do not
currently do
um and and some other benefits I think
if we can study the the use of bail
Commissioners and the use of a new
system of magistrates at the same time
we're implementing this type of
legislation I think that would be a an
excellent combination
thank you further questions from the
committee
representative Newman
thank you
um my question has to do with the the
limitations that are in this bill the 20
the 24 hours
but they all exclude holidays and and
weekends
and additionally it also has language in
there between if you're arrested between
8 A.M and 1 pm and the person's attorney
is not available which would probably be
the case with public attorney
um and it also has that 36 hours and
then it says not including Saturdays and
holidays so it seems like
the elimination of this of the
discretion being taken away from the
judges and the bail Commissioners may
have an even greater impact if this bill
is passed then probably the statistics
you just mentioned or did it include
that in your analysis
um so thank you for the question I have
two parts I think to my answer one is
the
um for folks who are so detention
hearings happen currently and these
rules apply to to those folks
um so the uh so the Saturday Sundays
holidays in the eight to one thing Are
all uh exist under the current system of
detention hearings which we have
in terms of the impact on the courts
What in in every one of our circuit
courts Monday mornings are a huge bail
day I mean that's all they can do and
that's what they do in this you know
adds to what is going to happen on a
Monday bail hearing day
um so the the the burden on this was
really focused not so much on the totals
that I gave because those totals are the
same it affects the distribution so that
what we're talking about is is Monday
morning is going to be Monday morning
Monday afternoon
and sort of balancing one of the other
aspects of of what the clerk has to do
is and what the counties have to do
because these are all people that will
be incarcerated in a County Jail is
coordinating the individual so that a
particular time they're sitting in front
of the camera that is set up in uh
Concord circuit court so that the
judging Concord circuit court is seeing
the person who is who is in Merrimack
County Jail at the same time at the
right time so that we have this process
in the in the clerk's office is
coordinate that with the county jails
and that in and of itself is just a
process and in part what we just don't
know is
what is the maximum number of video
hearings that we can have in one day
because within the county system they
typically have one camera available in
in one room available for their video
arraignments and once that maxes out so
once you've hit capacity of that system
and people have to be arraigned on a
particular day that's going to result in
more transports from the county to the
courthouse so the so then we have the
coordination of the sheriff's offices to
transport an individual from the county
jail to the courthouse and
possibly back to the county jail
so there's there's a great deal of
coordination that has to happen both in
terms of video and in transport that all
has to happen in a very short window of
time in terms of the coordination and
even knowing sort of who's going to
who's subject to these things so there's
a great deal of work but it What What In
terms of what you highlighted that sort
of focus is a great deal of attention on
Monday morning
thank you for answer follow-up
so I guess I just want to get to the
basic question does the does the loss of
discretion without having bail
commission is available
make the situation with felonies first
on the Circuit Court
more better or or worse
because that discretion is not there so
what it does is is it adds what I said
at the beginning which is about 3 500
new hearings so that's 3500 events where
today a bail commissioner might be
handling that that under this bill would
bypass bail Commissioners and have that
person appear in front of a judge so
it's about 3 500 cases
annually that currently based on sort of
past or past numbers
um
would now result in a detention hearing
before a circuit court judge that
currently doesn't have that detention
hearing process thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill was not testified in this bill
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on Senate bill 252. foreign
the committee will be in recess for Mr
chairman
I wonder if we'd be able to or we're
going to okay let me just finish we're
going to be in recess for about
um 40 minutes
um we're going to have Republicans we're
gonna have a short caucus right now and
um then we'll meet back everybody in
about 40 minutes
yeah we are we're going to exec a few of
these other bills no no
good afternoon at this point we are
going to open the executive sessions and
we are going to begin with Senate bill
number 130 and I recognize
representative janvarin for a motion
chairman I move ought to pass on Senate
Bill 130. second
would you like to speak to your motion
representative
uh it's quite obvious that the judicial
branch needs this type of training
available and the police station
training is willing to do so so if the
Bills should pass and allow them to work
to collaboratively
representative Stone would you like to
speak to you second Mr cherry wood after
hearing testimony I think it's a prudent
course of action to get the address
training needs that they desire
further discussion
seeing none Alaska courts call the
rolled motion on Floors ought to pass
and Senate bill 130.
ice chair roads yes representative Pratt
representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
Jennifer
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes
representative gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes
representative Sue Newman
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy
CE yes motionless unanimous 19-0
motion being unanimously ought to pass
on
Senate Bill 130 is there any objection
to consent
hearing none it will go on the consent
calendar and I hereby close the
executive session
and does anyone know where
representative Pratt is we do not
from
see if you can find representative Pratt
okay
at this point I'm going to open the
executive session on Senate Bill 249 and
I'm going to recognize myself for a
motion I'm going to move to retain do I
hear a second seconded by representative
Barry Gathering
and I will speak to my motion um and
this is going to be a broad broad
reaching speech generally on bail
um as the committee knows at the
beginning of this year I made a
commitment to everyone that we're going
to retain these bills and we were going
to find the best
parts of them
in order to come up with a good piece of
legislation
politics being what it is we need to
come up with something this year
and I am going to work with
representative here at gathright to come
up with a good piece of legislation
based on a couple of them that are in
front of us and one of those is not
representative Senator abbas's Bill so
we are going to retain that like we did
all the other ones
and we're going to continue to work over
this weekend and come up with something
that I hope we can all support
so having said that with regard to this
bill
um
I don't believe that the support is
there for it regardless of how any of us
may feel
um I think it's best to hold off let's
retain it with the other ones and see
what we can come up with in the meantime
that we can get to the floor that will
pass the whole body and that we know
will pass the Senate
would you like to speak to your second
representative Catherine
thank you Mr chair
um as stated we've had a lot of
conversations about all the bills that
we've had that related to bail or bail
reform
um and for the most part the committee
has agreed that we would save one for a
committee so that we could kind of take
really do a deep dive in so
um I'm going to ask everyone to
vote yay on this particular Bill and see
what happens after that
and I would just add that it has not
been easy retaining all these bills as
I'm sure some of you know there's been
enormous pressure brought to bear and I
have stood and held it to this point but
as we get closer
um it's becoming more and more evident
that we need to we need to move a little
bit quicker on some of these so that's
what we're going to work hard over to do
any further discussion on the retention
of this bill
seeing nonetheless the court to call the
roll the motion on the floors to retain
Vice chair wrote yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec
representative pru
no
representative janvrin
representative Manion
no
representative Reed yes
representative Stone
yes
representative tensar yes
representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Newman
osunamin yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes no
representative Newell yes
representative salig yes representative
wheeler I started this trend and I will
proudly vote yay
chairman Roy
the chair will die motion s 17 3.
motion carries the bill is retained
I hereby close the executive session
I opened the executive session on Senate
Bill 245
and I recognize a representative
oh Murphy for a uh
motion
yeah we can do that first
well thank you Mr chair um I have an
amendment that's been handed out
um I think everybody has a copy and I
would like to uh move to Auto pass um
with this amendment
to adopt the amendment
um second is anyone second
Ed by representative pru
Itt
Mr chair
if it yeah I would just like to make it
click it's uh
everybody has that Amendment 2023-1305h
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to your uh motion sure thank you
Mr chair
um yes this bill
um excuse me this statute uh is an old
one from I believe the 1920s and uh came
before us at the the uh behest of the
hotel association stakeholders
um given a need for an update
and
um this uh current Amendment will
address the issue they had that required
before a book or card system
um method of bookkeeping which is
certainly outdated and they would like
to have the option to use more current
data collection kind of
um tools like computers and those kinds
of things so um this amendment
um does a few things it changes the
requirement for a book or card system to
be held and now we'll just re uh require
that a record of the registered guests
will be would be kept it also deleted
the word each as it re it would
reference guests who were required to
provide their name for the hotel record
it also deleted the
um necessity and the reference to sign
as it as to a signature for registering
guests
um so now it's just their their name and
it also deleted the option for a
registering guest to use any name other
than their legal name
so it's pretty simple but we'll meet the
needs of the stakeholders and
um it was a lot of discussion amongst
members and I think this is a is a good
Amendment we'll address the issue thank
you thank you representative pru would
you like to speak to you second was it
she said okay
um I I agree with uh some of the members
um that the bill did raise an
interesting question actually some
random citizen testified that brought
that
um that in light of the Constitutional
Amendment we just passed it is worthy of
further discussion as to whether or not
that should continue to be allowed or it
should be tailored or all done with all
done away with all together
um having said that
I don't want to punish the the folks
that brought this forward asking for a
simple fix but
making it into a huge thing at this
point I am going to look at it over the
summer and speak with some folks and see
if it's the legislation is possibly
beneficial in the fall but right now
we're just going to fix what they asked
us to and we'll examine the issue that
came up during testimony later
any further discussion representative
salik I saw you representative thank you
Mr just if you're working on something
that would
uh get rid of this outdated law or out
of Warrant requirement I'd be happy to
work with you in a bipartisan way on
that yeah I appreciate that I'm not sure
either one of those is what will happen
but we're going to look at it and see
um representative scitec
I intend to vote IES or uh
yay depending on what whatever is going
on at the moment but I share the concern
we have a right to privacy and you said
it all and uh I think we have to keep
that in mind thanks
see no further discussion I'll ask the
court to call the roll the motion on the
floor is ought to pass oh adopt the
amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pru
yes representative jandron
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
gathrate yes representative Muse yes
representative Bolden
yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
um amendment is adopted 22.
the Imam was adopted it's now open for
further motion
I recognize representative Murphy
I moved uh that we vote ought to pass as
amended
a second
yeah would you like to speak to your
motion representative Murphy
I know I think I think everything was
said thank you
representative jambrian
thank you Mr chairman uh I think I may
have told the committee that uh we had
an incident in the town of Seabrook
recently where a false alarm was called
into the police by a person that was an
Uber trying to protect her boyfriend
from being arrested for shoplifting and
it turned out to be a active shooter
slash bomb threat
through the investigation
the police were able to determine where
this person was staying by utilizing
this law they were able to call the the
hotel
and say do you have so-and-so registered
here and they said yes so this law
helped the investigation and quick
resolution of that uh that incident in
the town of Seabrook so I support the
bill as amended
thank you representative and I do think
that there is a certain value in the law
especially given the transient nature of
people in a in a hotel versus people who
there's a record of where they live in a
permanent residence but I do think we
have to balance that with the um the
wishes of the people for privacy so
we'll be looking at both sides of that
very closely if we think of any new um
legislation that would be necessary
further discussion
see none of us could call the role
representative I just can't help but
observe we can get make a lot law
enforcement a lot easier by getting rid
of the Fourth Amendment reasonable
search and seizure just going
I think that would be a different motion
um
I'll ask the clerk to call the rule and
um the motion on the floor is ought to
pass is amended
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvran yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzai yes
representative gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yep representative wheeler
chairman Roy charbels yes motion is
unanimous the motion of ought to pass is
amended is unanimous and anyone object
to consent seeing none that will go on
the consent calendar hereby close the
executive session
and what's next
I hereby open the executive session on
Senate bill number seven six and I
recognize representative Rhodes for a
motion
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
ask the committee to reconsider their
vote on Senate Bill 76
do I hear a second seconded by
representative wheeler would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would thank
you Mr chairman uh so just as a friendly
reminder to Senate Bill 76 it was the
bill that had to do with reporting uh a
death if a person comes across it and or
the lack of not reporting it when you
know about it and the committee all
worked you know really hard and we you
know I hurried up and I got the
amendment taken care of and then that
day we were working very quickly to move
through and when the Senate bill came
back we were the amendment we all
completely forgot to put the title of
the bill and our friend representative
wheeler remembered after we all voted
and we found out we needed to hold on to
that in order to to introduce that
amendment to name the bill and I would
just ask everybody to please reconsider
so that we can do that for this family
and could you refresh us on what the
name and why oh sure uh
Maryland Maryland I think I believe that
this is going to be called Maryland's
law and it was the um the young lady
that testified very unfortunate that her
grandmother had passed away and it seems
that a family member just
chose to not report that and this bill
will be named after the the woman's
grandmother
wheeler would you like to speak to you
second I have nothing to add to what
Representatives Rhodes said other than
to say that representative mannion was
actually the person who reminded me I
was just the one who did the life work
but
it's a real great teamwork there
um
any further discussion
seeing none Alaska clerk to call the
roll on reconsideration
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative Prue
representative janvin absolutely
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
Kathryn
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the cleric votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salig yep representative wheeler
chairman Roy gerbilts yes motion is
unanimous
motion is unanimous the vote is open for
reconsideration and I recognize
representative wheeler for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I motion ought to
pass on SB 76 and would offer Amendment
1325h
for consideration second about
representative mannion and the motion is
to adopt the amendment
1325h to sp76 I have a question
I have a question
can the committee recommend two
amendments because it was already
amended we already passed Amendment so
when it goes to the floor will it will
have two amendments
no because we have to pass the committee
Amendment on the floor we can also
reject it
okay so um would you like to speak to
your motion representative wheeler I
think representative Rhodes said it very
well this is just to honor the
grandmother of the woman who took the
time to come speak before us and gave us
really heartfelt and Powerful testimony
that I think we all took with heart and
uh it's a good honor to pass this
legislation and an even better one to
honor her wish to name it after her
grandmother herself thank you
um would you like to speak to Second
representative Manny I was covered thank
you
any further discussion
go ahead Mr chair so I do have a
question actually
um
so we just reconsidered the vote
so does that actually that that Nolan
voids everything we did last week so do
we actually have to now vote on the
amendment that was first brought that
had the language that we wanted
uh I think that all we reconsider was
the final vote which was ought to pass
okay very good very good after we had
already adopted the amendment okay
um I am going to hold on to this though
after we vote today just to make sure
it's okay with the clerk in case we need
to take it up again to re-adopt all the
Amendments okay
um who else had representative pru
not a big fan of naming bills because
we'll start with this one and then we're
going to have to name every bill
so
unless there's something really
important that a name needs to go with
it not a fan
representative wheeler
it's in response to what representative
proof said I I hear that concern
um I think there has been two bills that
we've seen already in this committee
that have had names one of them last
week and I was so I hear that concern
but I I think this is an instance in
which naming the legislation is is
warrant
you could representative um
um Bolden
thanks um not to be controversial but
anyone who has a problem with the
proposed amendment could take the
opportunity
to make a restroom break or something
out of respect for the family given the
subject matter
um for what it's worth we don't name a
lot of stuff
just a suggestion you don't always have
to vote especially because some men and
I'm sure we're all in agreement it is a
legitimate um suggestion representative
my heart's not really in this because I
I don't like to vote for Resolutions and
I don't like to vote for naming laws so
I'm going to agree with a representative
Prue but I will of course vote for the
amended bill
thank you I see that both of the um
both of the representatives who grew up
in Edna
seem to not like Eamon Bells I I feel uh
that um yeah okay any further discussion
oh representative Newman
oh yes on this vote for the amendment
does not really change the bill it'll
always be referred to by the official
name and this is just a short title and
it's a note in the bill itself
yeah I don't even believe that this
would show up in the books that this
name part I don't think
um but I'm not sure
maybe that's not in chapter law
representative Bolton I'm personally
feeling really anxious about this two
amendments thing so I'm just gonna go
call Paul as I said
oh you already talked to him oh I guess
I missed that detail okay yeah and
anyway I'm gonna have Karen hold on to
it for a day or so so I can check to
make sure okay would hate to have to
have this whole conversation all over
again
okay I'll ask the court to call the roll
the motion is about to pass as amended
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
yes representative scitec
representative Prue no thank you
thank you representative janfrin
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright
representative news yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes represent
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy
um vote is 18 2.
is there any objection to consent
oh what was this
oh see all that talk I thought we
already did that okay
yeah
oh you were confused too okay uh at this
point I I
think
what's next
representative wheeler I recognize you
for a motion
thank you Mr chairman
emotion
OTP as amended for Senate bill 76.
second about representative Maine
any further discussion is necessary is
there
please call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative Prue
negative
representative Jan wren yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
gathrate
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative uh sunuman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler okay
I had something in my throat iPod yay
chairman Roy
CE yes vote is 19-1 representative prudi
object to consent
[Music]
it is closed and Will Go On consent
at this point I'm going to open the
executive session on no I'm not
represent an SB 244 and I'm going to
recess the executive session on 244.
and I'm going to open is there anything
else you had to open and close
252 is
oh yeah and I'm going to open the
executive session on Senate Bill 252 and
I'm going to recess the executive
session on 252.
and the committee is done for the day we
will
tentatively be meeting again next
Wednesday to take up these two bills yes
which one was that
oh because I'm working on that one I
might be doing an amendment
I might be doing an amendment to that
yeah we have till June
the email you sent me after the hateful
email that I got your response was very
thoughtful and kind and I just wanted to
let the committee know I really
appreciated your support after having
gotten such
ugly speech sent to me yeah that that
person is um is I don't even want to say
right I want to be public in thanking
you for for your response I really
appreciate it you're very welcome thank
you very much
anyone else have anything else before we
go all right enjoy your long weekends
and just for the record
yeah I was tricking Mr chairman also um
just for you know
um
yeah we have session tomorrow try not to
forget that and
no he I had a train of thought and he
just drove it right into a ditch I don't
know what it was next week next week
yeah next week
um we're going to do these two bills and
we're done for the year
yeah I know
um
we could have been but you voted no one
that name loss on
are we recessed or no or is the meeting
closed
yeah give it a minute Jonah you'll see
so Mr chairman
representative janvard be quiet
we have to redo our redo
yes so last week
representative wheeler called the house
Clerk and he he told us to hold on to he
told us to hold on to the blurb and to
not submit it to his office for us to
reconsider our vote and we misunderstood
when he when he told representative
wheeler to just write the amendment
renaming the bill
I believe what he meant was rewrite
rewrite the amendment renaming the bill
in with the amendment that was already
written with all the language so now we
need another amendment to bring it all
together
so okay so we're not going to transmit
that bill we're going to hold it and
we'll take it up Wednesday in the
meantime someone will get the amendment
of the amendment on the amendment who
who owes me uh like a coffee or
something could have saved us the
trouble no I don't think so because we
don't have the amendment
thank you